Welcome to the h three podcast
experience.
We're trying to compete with Joe Rogan
over here.
Hell yeah.
My theory is that a podcast can never
compete with an experience.
He's gotten an experience.
Right.
So I'm trying to,
even the playing field a little bit.
You need to see weed pills or something.
Yes,
I need some kind of supplement
experience supplement,
but they get to hymns.
It Felix Gray and audible for sponsoring
us today.
And if you haven't already guessed
today,
I would say are good.
Arguably the most successful youtuber of
all time.
Bieber.
Yeah,
I can't,
there's no argument.
No fight number.
Can we say number two?
No,
because like the idea is that like if
you make stuff outside of Youtube,
you're more successful.
I don't think that's true.
I'm saying like their youtube or is make
way more money than me.
More people.
I mean,
I don't think it's like,
you know,
it's legit and successful just cause you
know,
in my mind I feel like it,
there's some truth to it.
If you can escape in a way,
it's almost,
it is an escape because it,
it really frees you,
like what you do with your comedy acts
is kind of not compatible with youtube.
You think?
Kind of,
I dunno.
Uh,
well it's like maybe,
maybe not the whole stage and the
lighting and all the coordination and
disappearing for a year.
Yeah.
Well that,
that's really why I left or not left eye
when I was,
you moved on.
I just wanted to do live stuff.
I mean,
even when I was posting the early
videos,
like I just wanted to perform on stage,
I was doing theater.
That's where we want it to do.
When I was performing those videos,
like I'd be like,
I really want to go to stage with these.
And then I performed them on stage and
if I had posted the video,
it wouldn't get that much of a reaction
when you realized like,
Oh,
if I didn't post this stuff and people
heard it for the first time and the room
was,
it was,
it was a exciting so,
well,
I didn't introduce you Bo Burnham.
Okay.
Um,
basically I would say one of the most
beloved comedy acts for the past decade,
including two of my favorite,
what and make happy on Netflix.
Netflix.
What's on Youtube?
Yeah.
What's back on Netflix?
It's bad.
It's everywhere.
It's everywhere folks.
And he's just written and directed a new
movie that's out today on limited
release,
right?
Nationwide in two weeks.
Yeah,
in New York and La.
And then it'll be out somewhere else.
Eighth Grade,
which by the way is getting rave reviews
and 98% on rotten tomatoes.
Whoa.
Let me hit you with the sound.
Soundbar 99 now they raised like,
you know what?
Fuck that 99.
Ooh,
can we get it to a hundred?
Can we off that one fucking loser?
No,
we can't.
Are you sure?
Go for it.
Yeah.
Can you and the interns on it?
He is where he's up to word scenario.
Not you're good.
I would tell if he had a book hanging
on.
It's all good.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't let you and with that I'm
free,
but it does have 100% of my heart.
Appreciate it.
I went and I saw it last night.
It's very kind of,
I missed the screening and I absolutely
loved it.
You missed the screening.
I missed the screening,
so
I went and saw it last night.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
Um,
how,
how are you feeling about it?
I mean,
the movie's out.
It's getting rave reviews.
I'm feeling great.
I want to say I'm really grateful to be
here.
I'm a fan of yours,
Ethan.
I'm a fan of the podcast.
It's true.
Um,
you know,
and um,
though I haven't been like posting a lot
on youtube.
I'm watching the shit all the time.
Yeah.
All the time.
I mean,
like my main relationship with the
Internet is as a viewer and as someone
just on,
can I ask,
who do you frequent?
I was like,
who do you like?
You're,
you know,
you're one of the few people,
like it's really popular that I watch.
I mean,
I don't know if it's like it to me,
but like I,
I,
it's sort of what the movie ended up
being like,
I love people in the Internet that no
one's watching.
Uh,
I love the review review,
Bruh.
I love him under review Bra,
the report of the week.
Oh yeah,
he's,
yeah,
he's a legend and incredible.
Um,
but I really love like people on the
Internet that no one's watching.
So I'll often like search something and
then view it by Upload Day.
I mean,
you're in the nitty gritty.
Yeah.
So I love deep dives.
Like there's this dude who's a hoarder
who cooks hot dogs on candles and it's
very nauseated and see,
have character or is it just the,
it's the intrigue of it all.
Does he have character?
Like it seemed very entertaining or no,
it's bone chilling.
It's chilling.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's like him.
Like can we show,
we give him a shout out.
I don't know his name and I don't know
if he's in.
No,
but really it's like he takes a tour of
his like hoarding house and he cooks
like he called some sausages and there's
a video of him making sausages and
peaches.
It's absolute incredible.
We could probably pull it up.
Yeah.
It's a lot of cooking sausages and it's
really not the hot dogs.
And sausages or the PT calls it sausages
and peaches,
but it is most certainly hot dogs.
Okay.
But no,
I just like,
I,
I've,
I dunno,
but yeah,
no,
I,
I've watched a lot of [inaudible] them
from the background and I want to talk a
lot about that.
But first I want to ask like,
what was your motivation almost for
writing this film?
Because it's a departure,
it's kind of a surprise to a lot of your
fans of like,
Oh wow,
where did this movie come from?
It's very specific.
Yeah,
it'd be too,
with a very specific narrative,
like you had a purpose.
So I'm wondering what,
what was,
what motivated you to go that route?
It was like,
it's about a girl,
like a 13 year old girl last week,
eighth grade.
And you know,
I did stand in for like,
and found it already by the way.
Amazing.
We'll cut it.
I,
it'll be,
it'll be a hard letting me Andreas
conversation.
Um,
I I,
you know,
perform standup for a long time and I
was feeling anxious and I wanted to sort
of talk about the internet and my own
anxiety in a way and sort of I had felt
like my anxiety for a long time.
It was like very specific to me being a
25 year old comedian with like an
audience.
Um,
and then I would like do my shows and
like young kids would come up to me and
say they felt like me and they felt like
they knew what I was going through.
Even when I was talking about was like
being on stage in front of thousands of
people.
I'm like,
why is this resonating with you?
Um,
and I just think that sort of pressures,
the weird pressures that are usually
only afforded to like d list celebrities
have now been democratized and given to
everybody.
So I was always interested in like,
who are telling a story about someone on
the Internet that nobody's watching.
Cause the Internet tends to end,
the culture at large tends to only talk
about the people on the Internet that
are being seen.
But the majority of people on the
Internet and there's a lot more and more
who are just talking to the camera and
nobody's watching.
That's 99% of the videos that are
uploaded.
99.9
you know,
and the kind of,
the only thing we talk about is like
people that go viral and as someone that
went viral,
it's really not that interesting.
You know what I mean?
It's like the actual interesting thing
is just trying to engage with this thing
and trying to be seen and trying to be
heard.
And to me the people that weren't being
heard,
we're actually engaged in a much deeper,
more honest and thing.
Well there was one of the central themes
I think that I extracted from it was
like how social media or this abundance
of all this going on with youtube and
twitter and instagram is affecting kids.
Cause I think when there's a five year
difference between us,
but when I grew up there was no like
grow hap as a kid was hard enough.
But then when you have all this new
social media introduced to them and the
way that you portray the girl,
how she's glued to the social media,
it was very accurate.
I think.
Like how is this affecting kids?
I don't know all the time is that I
don't quite know exactly like,
and truly it was me wanting to talk
about how it felt to me and how it felt
to me was it made me feel nervous and
weird and unsure of myself.
And that seems like,
I mean social media.
Yeah.
Just having to sort of represent
yourself,
having to live your life and then also
live your life on this other place.
And then the sense of like,
because of that floating behind yourself
through situations.
Um,
I just think it's like weird and
disembodied and like a little
disassociated or something.
But more than anything it was like I,
I'm happy for people to like leave the
movie thinking about that stuff,
but I don't want the movie to be like a
Ted talk or like,
I mean some like finger wagging shit
cause that's what so annoys me.
It wasn't,
by the way,
let me just say one more thing.
Yeah,
but,
but like that,
I dunno,
it just feels like the Internet hasn't
even,
in least in popular media hasn't even
been described,
let alone figure it out.
Like so.
So,
um,
yeah,
I just wanted to portray it and portray
it,
how it feels to her and me a little bit,
which is just weird.
It's just like,
it's a lot,
but it's not like,
it's just shitty.
It's not like,
it's like we should just,
Oh,
if we had through our phones and the
ocean and we'd be happy.
It's like,
it's both.
We're super connected,
we're super lonely,
we're super stimulated,
we're super numb,
we're self expressing and objectifying.
It's like,
yeah,
I wouldn't be here without the Internet.
You know what I mean?
Like obviously I'm so,
so grateful for it.
Um,
but also it's,
you know,
there's,
there,
there may be a happy medium between like
60 minutes talking about like narcissist
the kids and like come on creators or
whatever the fuck youtube conversation
is where it can't
self examine it at all.
I feel like,
well I'm on my part,
I'm a grown man more or less.
And I've recently pretty much quit using
social media because it's honestly too
much for me,
for me,
like,
uh,
like even me for for a long day,
I had like a quota for myself for,
I was like,
I need to post every day on twitter
once.
Yeah.
Cause in a way it's like if I don't
tweet,
do I exist still?
Like am I still in the minds of these
people?
And I found by the way,
that the answer is very much,
yes,
you still do exist if you don't tweet.
But like there was just a really
unhealthy interaction I had with it.
Like checking it first thing in the
morning.
I had that too.
I started to sitting down and he would
be on my phone.
I was like,
this is fucked up.
This is totally,
because you don't really get a lot of
time out of that.
You sit down at what do you mean?
What does that buy you?
Like 30 seconds,
30,
40 minutes at most,
right.
That's a edition.
We'll get into that.
Um,
but yeah,
I,
uh,
but that,
that is part of what the mood is hoping
to get at is that like,
it isn't like sit down to pee and you
use your phone for that.
So you would just open twitter really
fast while you were on the John.
Yeah.
And if it's cold,
I'll piss through the space and the,
the seat in the bowl and all over my
pants.
It's nothing happens.
Does that happen to you still?
They step in when I was a kid and I
would have like a morning wood and like,
cause your Dick points down into the
bowl.
Yeah,
definitely.
But you're still able to pay through the
whole soft.
Yeah,
I was just kidding.
Uh,
so,
uh,
yeah.
Um,
I was trying to explore that.
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
I'm just like,
totally kidding.
I just made up a really specific joke
that's never happened.
You've never paid through the crack when
you were a kid.
All right,
let's get on.
Let's get it.
Let's get off.
I tried to be vulnerable with you.
But yeah,
I think like people look at me,
I'm like,
man,
I'm so glad I'm not an eighth grade he
morning,
I'm so glad I'm not so awkward on,
I don't have to deal with social media.
And I'm like,
you're the worst people in social media
or 30 year olds and young people in
their late twenties like from talking
with the kids,
the kids have the best chance of being
shell on it cause they like actually
have a little bit of self awareness and
kind of have grown up with it.
It's the 30 year olds that pretend like
they're not,
you know,
addicted to it and becoming a suit.
I just like,
I can't believe what my friends look
like online.
I came,
there was so many people that I,
I don't mind in real life and I hate
interesting hate them and there's never
the opposite.
There's never any like what is it that
they do online that makes you hate them?
It just so transparent,
right?
What everyone's doing,
things trying to look like peachy and or
no,
trying to look pg or trying to or trying
to be ironically peachy or you know like
uh,
I mean humblebrag is the word of the
21st century.
I heard you say something that I really
liked is something that's been ringing
with me.
It was like if you ironically hate
something,
it's not really better than like if you,
ironically if you're self aware of doing
something that you'd have like,
yeah,
it's not really different.
Yeah.
No everyone,
like you see that on a lot of people
being
like clickbaiting ironically,
but it's like,
well you still know you're still doing
that.
It's like,
and I did that when I was 16 and 70.
It was like by my merge,
I'm a sellout.
It's like that.
No,
you're still a fucking stuff.
Like it doesn't being self aware of
saves you nothing the most.
And it's like the ironic shit,
the most ironic shit online is like old
spice commercials and Geico commercials
where they're going on and being like,
this is a Geico commercial wink.
And it's like,
fuck you.
There's like dead pool,
it's like a $200 million movie winking
at you.
And it's like,
is that cool?
I don't know what I mean,
I'm just saying like this sort of like
surrealist,
cool,
crazy adult swim.
Like,
uh,
aesthetic has been totally co opted by,
like all state,
all state.
But you know what I'm saying?
I feel like it's a,
I dunno,
it just feels to me.
Let me ask you,
how does making a movie compare to your
other creative endeavors that you've
done so far?
It was good,
man.
I was just desperate to work with other
people.
I was like,
um,
you know,
stand up,
you just look to yourself.
And I was so tired of my own head.
I mean,
I was just so tired of my voice and my
face.
Um,
so I just wanted to work with people
again.
I did theater like growing up and that's
what I really love and that's what I,
when I fell in love with ships.
So,
um,
yeah,
it was just about working with people
and getting out of my own head.
And that was nice.
That's awesome.
Because like trying to explore my own
anxiety by being alone on stage.
How far it's surprisingly ended up
making it worse.
Um,
you'll have problems with anxiety.
Oh yeah.
I also have suffered from that,
but I'm curious,
have you found something that's helped
you?
How long have you been suffering from
anxiety?
Longer in hindsight than I thought when
I was in high school,
Sophomore year I was in the hall in,
out of the hospital with stomach
problems thinking,
uh,
I just like,
I did like drank barium thinking I'm
having all this like most of the poles
in my intestines and I was just nervous
shitting my pants every day.
It's funny,
I find it interesting that you weren't
aware that it was anxiety.
We're feeling will,
it was so constant that I didn't think
it could have been.
It was every day.
Um,
which actually probably should have
pointed to anxiety,
but,
um,
and then it really,
when I was 23,
I had my first panic attack on stage and
that was like,
oh shit.
How did you,
how did the show continued?
It continued.
I've had like,
you know,
push through it.
Yeah.
I've had about 10 onstage and shit.
What happens in that moment?
You become like very self aware tunnel
vision,
like tunnel vision and then like,
you know,
numb body and then just a total like out
of body feeling.
And what's so weird,
it's so weird about it is that it's
with,
it's,
it's happening within the structure of a
show that is rich enough to but to the
word,
you know what I mean?
So it's like,
I can't even like go,
oh,
I'm feeling like I have to,
I have to like say it ends up like I'm
in groundhog's day and I like,
or like I have a script they have to
keep to,
so I have this inner monologue freaking
out and then I'm having to perform by
drowned that you're able to still like
perform the script while having a
somewhat out of body experience.
Yeah,
it was,
but it was like,
it was like I'd be a little out of
breath.
So I'd be the entire show for 20 minutes
would be existing like on like the
inhale kind of.
Um,
it definitely wasn't my best work.
Hmm.
Um,
you know,
uh,
do you remember for me my anxiety,
I think I was diagnosed with generalized
anxiety disorder and I had like a very
specific moment of like almost breaking
like a breaking point where it just came
out of nowhere.
Did you have a moment like that?
It was actually,
I had a panic attack,
um,
in Providence,
Rhode Island,
which is funny cause like,
you know,
I've taught people that went to the
show.
I've heard this now,
don't,
you know,
I don't think my parents were there and
couldn't tell what was happening.
Providence,
Rhode Island,
it was like a theater,
like 3000 people had a panic attack.
It was really bad.
Um,
then went to New York,
had three shows,
had a panic attack in the middle show,
went to see the Martian the next day and
got very,
very angry because I,
it,
it wasn't about anxiety and I didn't
know it felt like so perfect for my
life.
Like how is this story about a guy alone
on Mars logged in it,
it felt so true to me.
And then it was just like about how he's
like a good botanists or something.
Movies probably chill.
I was just in a bad place and then I had
a panic attack on the train to DC the
next day.
Um,
which was another show and I had like,
this was like the first week of a tour,
there was like 45 shows and 50 days and
that was when I was like,
there's something going on here.
Yeah.
Like this is bad and I can never do this
again.
Um,
that,
that was the worst time of my,
I've had a pretty fortunate life.
That was definitely one of the hardest.
Yeah.
Stretches of my life.
And like how did you kind of get through
it?
I mean,
did you find at the time,
was it like for me it was almost
unbearable.
Like I couldn't even live,
I was like completely debilitated for
like six months.
I would say try meditation,
you know,
I haven't meditated for sure.
The problem is there's just a show every
night and there was like very like
surreal comical things where I'd be like
googling how to deal with stage fright,
you know,
before a show in front of 3000 people.
And the answers would be like,
don't worry,
like if you're pr,
if you're doing this in front of your
class or at town hall,
like people don't really care about what
you're saying.
I'm like,
no,
nope.
There's 3000 people that have paid $40
in her have waited like it is.
They do care.
Yeah.
It like really helped me to find out
that like Barbara streisand struggled
with Dell.
Like I actually really helped too.
It's such a weird thing,
like how you almost have to be more of a
fucking psycho to not experience
anxiety.
Exactly.
Like it's,
it's like being the president.
Like I dunno how you,
well,
I've long held that you have to be an
actual sociopath that even want to be
president.
Yeah.
So those guys don't feel like,
I just feel cold blooded.
Yeah.
We got a good one right now.
But yeah,
they're usually pretty bad.
Yeah.
He's,
I get the feeling he's
not having much self awareness,
self aware of moments right now.
Yeah.
No.
Um,
yeah,
my mind,
I know my body's on fire.
Um,
yeah.
Meditation.
What did you do dude?
The thing is like I'm not,
I'm like a somewhat sensitive guy,
but for some reason I never talked to
anyone about it.
Like I don't,
yeah,
I didn't say I was my biggest mistake
and that's what fucked me up for long.
And looking back in hindsight,
I was like,
why didn't I,
why was I so private about it?
Cause I thought I was,
I thought I was actually having like a
psychotic break.
I thought I was almost for sure that I
was schizophrenia and I was so crushed
by that fact and I felt like I would
crush my parents by telling them that.
And I felt just like I couldn't talk
about it at all and I held onto it just
hoping it would go away.
But it never did for me.
I don't know if you felt this,
like my worry was,
if I say it,
it's real.
You know what I mean?
Like,
if I admit that I'm going through there,
it's,
I've spoken it and now I'll never stop
thinking about it.
And it is for anyone worried about this.
It is the exact opposite.
It's like speaking,
it is the salvation.
So that's what helped me is when I
finally talked to them about it because
you,
it's just like,
it's like stand up.
It's just you and your head talking to
yourself and it makes everything so much
worse because when you've talked to
somebody about it,
first of all,
it's really a very,
very literal getting it out.
But then people can talk to and be like,
look,
you're not fucking,
you're not schizophrenia and you're not
dying.
It's just anxiety.
Like the things that I hoped for myself
but wouldn't believe people were
confirming for me,
that was the beginning of,
of,
of healing.
But I think the thing that really
changed for me was having a sick,
like a significant other and,
and my wife,
right?
Someone that really,
like I felt comfortable talking about it
and being myself and knowing that cause
a lot of the anxiety that I had was very
much like social and a lot of ways.
Yeah,
yeah.
Right.
Yeah,
of course.
So a lot of that was alleviated when you
find someone that like you think doesn't
care.
Yeah.
And you're alone in it together or
whatever,
and then you can hate the world army of
two or something.
Yeah.
You're going to get said.
That's beautiful.
Yeah.
I um,
I never took medicine though,
but frankly I wish I did.
Yeah.
I think it would've helped a lot.
I almost took Beta blockers for
performance when I felt like I was going
to Beta blockers.
We've talked about that here.
I don't know what the Fuck Beta
blockers,
I don't know anything and it sounds like
it's like a nineties board game or
something.
Yeah.
But I really feel like doing it.
Um,
but yeah,
man,
it's like the sort of my thing was like,
you know,
if I'm being truly honest with myself,
it's like the two sides of the same coin
that like I,
by speaking it out loud and seeing that
other people were going through it and
it ended,
it wasn't unique to my experience of
being because I just thought like,
oh it's,
this is happening to me because I'm
living an insane life in a very specific
circumstance.
You know
what I spoke and I realize like it's the
two things.
It was the thing I was most terrified of
and the thing that actually saved me,
which is like I'm not unique and I'm not
alone.
You know,
I think I was maybe deep down wanting it
to be singular because you know,
I've just,
you know,
I want to have a very singular
experience when I'm going through.
You can understand.
Right?
I think that that sort of mindset is
common too.
Anxious people and an idea of of it is
so visceral.
I sort of describe it like having
anxiety feels like,
um,
like I'm riding a bull,
like my bull is a nurse,
my nervous system and I just have to
hold onto it.
And then like,
being in the world feels like everyone
else's,
a,
an equestrian,
you know what I mean?
Just like perfectly in sync with their
own nervous system.
And it just,
it just isn't true.
Totally.
So many silent battles of it and
absolutely for some,
and it's so weird.
Like I,
uh,
I hadn't,
I co I saw a little bit of my special
that I didn't scenes,
you know,
in,
uh,
make happy the last one in two years and
I saw it and I couldn't,
I would not believe that person was
nervous.
Yeah.
I wouldn't believe I would think like,
oh,
he's talking about anxiety too,
just,
you know,
if he thinks it's like in and,
and,
but like he's not nervous.
And I was,
I frankly didn't know that it was such a
battle for you after the first show.
I saw obed sobbed backstage because,
because like,
I mean,
I slept two hours in the night before.
I was shaking like um,
yeah it uh,
yeah it was,
it was rough.
It was um,
it's incredible that even through that
you can still do shit cause like
thinking back on myself,
I wasn't famous at the time when I was
having my worst anxiety.
I still suffer from it a lot.
But like back in the day I was so like
even just talking to someone was almost
like a a bat like a real battle for him.
Yeah.
Going on a date was like the fuck and
like very much like what the movie is
that it describes is like these mundane
ordinary things can sometimes be the
bravest thing you can do it.
Right.
Exactly.
And that's what the movie was trying to
do is like portray it very much and it
works for third year.
I appreciate it.
And it was like 13 year old life for a
13 year old or someone with social
anxiety.
Every tiny moments feel like life and
death and it is,
it's so important to overcome it and
just say,
you know what,
I still have to do this.
And I feel like that is really what
makes you overcome it.
Yes.
And,
and,
and like I just think movies tend to
over us like push situations into drama
and confrontation that that needs to
justify it.
I think people are so fucking
nonconfrontational in real life.
So nonconfrontational like have you ever
like just raised your voice at the guy
in like the grocery store line and then
your heart is pounding for 40 minutes
afterwards?
Like yeah.
Like you ever seen an argument and
you're like,
Holy Shit.
You know what I mean?
I just think life is very,
the drama of our lives literally plays
out very small.
But subjectively in personally it's
very,
very big.
So the movie was just trying to be like,
can we show those tiny tiny moments very
successfully?
Like the scene where she's gone to the
pool party was just like,
I felt that so much.
You know what I mean?
And I think everybody watched you will
feel it so much.
So it definitely,
I love,
I love that so much capturing,
appreciate it.
What part is,
they're just not chill.
And we were trying to also like really
try to look at kids,
not nostalgically,
not like a memory,
but just try to see them like,
yeah,
yeah.
Aliens.
Like what if we just forgot what these
things meant to us in hindsight,
but just looked at it fresh and it's
like a pool party is like,
okay.
It's like,
okay,
so forget everything you know about
bombarding.
Forget that it's like a cultural
standard and realize that it's like,
okay.
It's like a bunch of kids whose bodies
are exploding half dressed hole in the
ground with water.
It's like,
wow,
how is this part of our lives?
Like?
Yeah.
How is this any pass it like rite of
passage for kids.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And finally,
like you just touched on it,
it doesn't get better as an adult go.
No.
Imagine I cannot mind taking off my
shirt fucking the worst ever.
I'm still like,
I wouldn't do that now.
I would just not do it.
Would you do,
would you go in with a shirt on?
Did you do that when you were a kid?
I would shirt on in the pool.
I'll tell you why.
I was shirt on.
I had a giant mole on my back has been
removed.
You can grab my mom did it by your mom.
It was camp.
She thought it was cancerous cause it
was like this fucking big but that's why
I wish shirt on now.
I keep the shirt on because um,
I'm fat.
Hold up.
Wait,
your mother,
your mother removed them all off your
back?
She,
okay.
Maybe I,
I described that weirdly.
She opted for it to be removed with or
you think I went and that's not what
happened at all.
Yeah.
No.
Okay.
Chill.
But we got that covered.
Okay.
That's good.
That's great.
Um,
yeah I would,
the sad shit is I would,
I would always work,
wear my tee shirt in the pool,
but I would like pretend like you mean
I'm like fall into the pool and be like,
Oh shit,
my shirts that's,
oh,
it's rough.
Right.
You know everyone,
even as a kid everyone's like,
come on dude.
Yeah.
You really,
really like,
you forget how self aware you are at
that age.
Like at that age,
you're in on the joke of yourself.
Like you're making fun of each other for
your voice is cracking and shit.
Like you know what's going on.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's brutal.
Sure.
On Man.
I've seen I fully clad,
I mean shoes and everything.
I've seen that before.
That's pretty well some stuff.
Cardio Wifi.
Yeah.
Damn.
So would you share it on these that you
insured on if you went to a pool party?
I don't pool.
Yeah.
I'm an endorsement.
Most definitely.
Do you have it?
Are you,
would you camp,
do you do any outdoor activities?
Would you play video games?
Like what am I outside people camp.
Yeah.
People.
Yeah,
there's fuckers out there.
They're all granola.
There's people out there that do stuff
and I'm,
and I'm genuinely jealous.
I say when I meet somebody,
I'm like,
you're the kind of guy that does stuff,
aren't you?
I know.
You know what I mean?
To me that's like,
yeah,
if I just like ate the right stuff and
went hiking and things,
I'd be happy.
But can you imagine going hiking?
No.
Can you imagine it ever went to Brian?
I've never went.
Never.
I just,
everyone hikes here.
I've never been,
they seem so happy.
They're out there dead behind the eyes.
They're lying about it.
No,
no way.
Dan,
are you a high,
I mean,
I know that like,
like Dan and Ian are very much people
that do stuff and I go,
who are you?
Well you meet these people.
They're like,
that was Dan.
Sorry Dan,
do go hiking.
No,
I mean when uh,
when a girlfriend a few years ago,
she would force me to all the time.
But that's not,
that doesn't really count.
You didn't like it,
you know,
it was that the main problem in the
relationship that she wanted to hike in
more ways than walk and hike.
Yeah,
exactly.
I'm going to dump her.
Yeah.
All right.
I like those people.
Are you jealous people that do stuff?
Cause I'm,
I know.
Oh,
they're always planning stuff.
They're going to like art exhibits.
Yeah.
They're also liking thrilled when they
find a bag of like dried cranberries.
Like,
I don't want to live that life.
Find a bag of drugs.
They're all like,
oh,
you know what I mean?
I didn't want to eat like Eggo waffles
and drink red bull.
I'm saying what,
what are you,
what's your,
what's your main hobby?
You probably work a lot.
No,
no,
I have a true,
true lazy streak.
Like truly,
um,
I like,
we'll sit around for a long,
long time and then like have a burst of
doing something.
And so what do you do when you're at
home?
Uh,
homeless men,
homeless men.
I've got dogs,
I've got the old friends.
Okay.
I,
uh,
kiss my dogs,
walk,
my girlfriend kiss.
I uh,
I um,
that's like a 1930s joke.
That was good.
Um,
I,
uh,
I've watched a lot of,
I went onto,
I know I watch a lot of stuff.
This is my problem.
I'm home all day and I don't know what I
do.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know if that's what you're
getting at.
I'll spend,
I'll be at home all fucking day and at
the end of the day I'll be like,
I did,
I don't even,
I didn't even like turn on a show and
watch a show.
Like,
at least I would be able to say I did
that,
but I don't know what I do.
I'll watch like videos of like 10 year
olds doing like Yankee candle halls.
What like 10 year olds?
Like they,
they,
there's a lot of Yankees.
Yeah.
Like 10 year old kids that like 300
subscribers that like go to Yankee
candle and bring a bunch of candles home
and they're low a hall.
A candle.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And they're like,
can I cough this?
It's peppermint.
And they smell like it smells like
peppermint.
It's the greatest shit ever.
Wow.
Okay.
I could tell you,
you're very,
you're home your home's men.
Yeah.
No.
I don't,
um,
you play video games?
I play if I,
I got psvr,
uh,
very excited about that.
If there was people I want to make my
movie for Vr,
if there was anything else might move.
You could be,
I wish it could be vr.
What does that mean?
You're just one of the kids Kinda,
yeah,
yeah.
Know what I'm saying?
The vr actually like inspired the movie
a little bit visually,
like wanting to feel like you're in this
thing.
Kind of looking around and like when
people start making like really cool
short films and stuff on that and
there's been a few,
it's going to be,
it's incredible.
It's like an,
it's a new medium,
not in the way like television and
movies are different mediums.
It's,
it's a different medium in the way.
Like movies and books are for me,
so I'm very excited about that.
But I've got switch.
I didn't plan Mario tennis aces.
Sweet.
I love the switch.
Yeah,
I just do handheld.
Yeah.
I don't fuck with the,
yeah.
Well do you play,
do you play on the TV or no?
See I do all that.
Yeah.
I liked the TV.
Yeah,
we're different,
but I heard it's better.
I heard it.
Right,
exactly.
You're going to have to split hairs.
The differences with like,
I'm a handheld switch,
man.
You're a,
but it's better graphics on the TV.
Yeah.
It's a TV for fuck sake.
That's right.
As a teen,
I checks out.
All right,
let's go to a quick break.
We will be right back when we get back.
I want to ask you all about like kind
of,
I've got a question.
Is the viral video debt,
you know,
let's ask that when we come back.
Thank you too for hymns for sponsoring
this episode of the h three podcasts.
Did you guys know that 66% of men start
losing their hair by age 35 now I
started using for hymns about I'd say
two days ago and I don't want to brag or
anything,
but not only is my hair looking more
luscious and thicker than ever,
but I'm also feeling particularly
powerful today.
Um,
guys,
it's much easier to keep the hair you
have then to replace the hair you've
lost.
Have you noticed that hairline receding?
Do you want to do something about it?
Well,
guess what?
Baldness is an option.
Okay.
And you don't have to be that guy any
longer.
The solution for hims.com
a one stop shop for hair loss,
skincare,
sexual wellness for men.
Ian,
for example,
started taking four hymns.
How long ago was it?
In?
About 24 hours ago,
24 hours.
I mean,
wow.
Results may vary.
I want to emphasize on that,
but as worked out really well for in,
yeah,
fix my hair line.
Change my rate.
Thank you so much Ian.
I'm glad we could help you out.
There is a well known generic equivalent
to name brand prescriptions to help you
keep your hair.
This is not snake oil pills or gas
station counter supplements.
This is prescriptions backed by science.
There's no waiting room,
no awkward doctor visits.
You're going to say the hours by going
to four hymns dotcom.
It's so easy.
Dan,
what is your opinion of four hymns?
It's done a lot of good for me.
Um,
I you as you,
as you can see,
we are all feeling great and our hair
is,
I don't want to say super saying,
but I mean we're feeling really good
about it.
Let's just put it that way.
The products get shipped directly to
your door.
After you answer a few quick questions,
a doctor reviews it and prescribes you
the medicine.
So here's what you need to do or right
flipping.
Now my listeners get a trial month for
four hymns for just $5 today,
right now while supplies last.
See the website for full details.
This would cost hundreds of fricking
doll hairs that you went to a doctor or
a pharmacy,
so go to [inaudible] dot com slash age
three that's for him,
s.com/h
three four hymns dot cobbs slash h three
results may vary in this case,
but it's going to help you a lot.
Thank you to Felix Gray.
Guys,
if you're like me,
you spend a lot of time on the computer
a lot,
way too much and here's what you need to
know.
Those blue lights coming off there are
going to eff you the frick up.
That's why I recommend Felix Gray
glasses.
Check this out.
These glasses block out the blue light
to prevent digital eyestrain,
which can give you a headache,
dry eye,
and really just a whole magnitude of
issues that are just frankly going to
ruin your whole life.
Yeah,
it's tough out there folks,
and look,
you don't have to look like a no word.
If you're trying to use the computer all
day,
you can look stylish and slick and maybe
somebody will actually look at your
Dick.
I Dunno about touch,
but look,
yes,
the rest is up to you to secure.
A lot of us spend hours and hours in
front of the computer staring at screens
and it gets exhausting.
Even if you've never heard of digital
eyestrain,
chances are you've experienced it.
When I'm on the computer all day I get
headaches.
It sucks because I don't leave the
computer.
I never stopped.
I just sit there with a headache until I
got these glasses.
Beautiful.
The designed by Felix gray feel as great
lenses are specifically designed to
filter blue light and eliminate glare
from the screen,
which are the two main culprits behind
digital eyestrain.
They have blue light filtering
technology and bedded into the lenses so
you're there effectively without the
telltale yellow tint or color distortion
of other blue light filtering glasses.
Felix gray frames are handcrafted from
premium Italian acetate,
the same material used by the biggest
designer brands in the world,
and they're super stylish.
This is the touring style.
I love it because it makes me look
studious and handsome and sweet.
Assuming guy that's secretly just a nerd
that wants to spend 15 hours a day on
the computer,
but they don't know that because these
look cool.
No C prescription as necessary.
They're glasses that are available and
nonprescription reader and they've just
launched prescription lenses so everyone
can benefit from wearing a pair of Felix
grace.
All orders are shipped free and free
returns,
so you've got nothing to lose.
Folks.
Give it a shot.
Go to Felix gray glasses.com/h
leader.
Try a pair of Felix Gray glasses today.
That's Felix Gray,
glasses.com/h
three Felix gray,
three link is in the description.
Guys,
you've got nothing to lose.
Give it a shot.
If you have problems at the computer
with eyestrain,
try them on.
See if it doesn't change your life
forever.
Audible.
You know it.
You'll love it.
Guess what?
They've got a special offer that's going
to hook you in.
Check this out.
Audible has an offer that ends July 31st
of this year.
Amazon prime members can get audible for
$5 a month for the first three months.
That's like getting three months for the
price of one and after those three
months,
it's just $15 a month.
Now,
you know I love audible.
It's basically change the game for me
because I can listen to a book.
It's like doubling your productivity.
If you want to listen to a novel or I
get you know,
a self help book or you want to learn
whatever you're doing,
your exercise and your playing video
games,
there's nothing better than accompanying
those activities with audible.
At the same time,
folks,
audible has the largest selection of
audio books on the planet.
Guess what's on audible now,
Harry Potter,
the fricking books are all on audible
now.
The whole series,
I started listening to the first book.
It's an chanting.
It's a blast.
I've personally read all those books
there.
One of my favorite series guys.
If you haven't gotten into the Harry
Potter series,
now's a great time to try audible and
listen to those right flip.
And now,
Gosh,
darnit a audible members get a credit
every month.
Good for any audio book,
regardless of price and unused credit
credits roll over to the next month.
If you didn't like the audio book,
you can exchange it for another one.
No questions asked,
folks,
it doesn't get better.
Got The soundboard here,
I'm going to use it.
Your books are yours to keep with
audible.
You can go back and relisten to any
time,
even if you cancel your membership.
So go to audible.com/h
three podcast or text [inaudible]
podcast,
one word to 500 500 to get started.
And remember,
Amazon prime members can get audible for
$5 a month for the first three months.
That's like getting three months for the
price of one.
Come on.
And after that,
it's $15 a month.
So once again,
guys,
this offer ends July 31st go to
audible.com/h
three podcast,
one word.
Go listen to Harry Potter.
I'm telling you now is the time to get
your wand out and start doing some
Abracadabra or what does that one at?
All right,
you guys are gonna love it.
Hello.
And welcome back.
It's,
yeah,
boy,
go here.
Let me ask you this.
You had your big breaks.
This is a big thing for you,
right?
Elbows on the table.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I have things I'm not very self.
I do this a lot.
I know this.
We just talked about anxiety and now
call him on your mind.
Now that's hard.
Horrible.
Well,
you know,
I used to say fascinating.
It's a good word,
but I lean on it a little bit.
Yeah.
And I got mehmed into the fucking
ground.
That's incredible.
And I watched like late night shows and
I watched people and they say,
I listen to a lot of podcasts.
They say fascinating.
A lot faster pumps.
You can even have it sound bus.
You can tell what rose of listening.
You're like,
I can't get away from it.
You can tell what,
uh,
Bros had been listening to Jordan
Peterson by how all of a sudden they
start saying presupposition.
That's sort of saying presupposition.
I'm like,
that's cool Bruh.
I know where you got that.
Oh,
you love that word.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Dan,
just a man to come on.
This is not fascinating at all.
Not um,
yeah,
so we,
the presupposition was that you weren't
going to come in here.
This was pre suppose.
Um,
so let me ask you,
you came up,
I'm coming up.
I want the world to know.
I've got to let it show.
Yeah.
You got to let it chill.
This is so,
yeah.
I fucked you up.
You came up,
you went viral,
right?
Hell yeah.
I feel like back then going viral is
that a Hashtag Hashtag viral viral,
I became an internet sensation.
You what term I love and please keep
using it.
And it was true back then.
There was such thing as real.
I felt like it was real viral videos and
viral videos.
Yes.
Meant like from nothing.
From the depths of,
yeah.
It's bullshit of Youtube.
Libyan cannot go viral.
James,
I'm saying I'd love to check it.
You can't go.
That's not virality of virus.
Yeah.
It's like a dude fucked a monkey.
He got aids and from the depths of out
of nowhere,
aids was born exactly viral.
But it's like,
oh,
I got a cold.
It's like,
well the has been around.
That's not,
you know what?
That's a weird analogy.
It's a weird analogy,
but maybe,
you know what I mean?
It's more like you have 8 million
subscribers.
Most of your subscribers saw your
fucking thing.
It didn't go viral.
Yeah.
You just,
yeah,
exactly.
It's like,
I like,
my question is do viral videos still
exists because I don't see that
happening anymore.
They do.
I don't think like,
yeah,
I don't think I would would've worked.
No,
I don't think I would have been
discovered.
It's a bummer.
I don't like,
why is that?
We do think cause youtube turned into a
fucking studio and a and the network and
you go to the trending page and it's
fucking late night,
late night clips,
movie trailers and music videos.
It's like fuck.
Like,
you know what I mean?
Like when we started,
it was like this was going to be the
people's medium.
It was like cool and different and now
it's just like,
I don't know why they do.
I really,
I don't understand why they do that.
I don't either.
It's like,
dude,
just don't put that shit there.
They don't need the fucking views and
the best they do is like support their
creators.
But are they supporting like no,
the,
the little creators,
the ones with a bunch of subscribers
don't need help and I don't the
specifics.
I know people
are getting fucked over specifically,
but it's like,
yeah,
it's kind of like the class of 2006 to
11 rows or whatever and like,
or you know,
I think it's hard to become anything
now.
I think like the established,
it's really hard to break through.
Yeah,
and the only people that I see breaking
through now are basically people who are
producing.
Just really just really the worst stuff
that's very easily consumable.
That's very clickable.
I think the thumbnail and the title are
so important.
Now let's walk through that.
It's really,
that's like people start there and then
work backwards.
Money.
Yeah.
Cause I remember I all my videos are
posted like lowercase,
just the title of the song you mean?
And I remember like even me later in the
clips I had to do big capital Bo Burnham
hd,
whatever the fuck.
Um,
but uh,
that's not,
but like bill worst bill wirtz,
the guy that did the history of
[inaudible] is the one exception.
I think there are some others.
I'm sure there are.
And,
and,
and again,
it's not,
it's not that,
I wouldn't say it's not the kids,
the specific people posting themselves
that aren't a value.
It's just I think the value system or
whatever that's like,
that you're taught to,
you know,
I don't think it encourages people to be
creative like it used to.
Right.
Or got out of the way.
It's like,
I dunno.
It's crazy.
Well,
a lot.
I don't think it was all going to turn
into blogging.
Yeah.
And like,
that's cool if you've logged,
but like even musicians,
like on youtube,
they're like little indie musicians
start their music video with like,
hey guys,
this is my music video.
I hope you check it out.
And then it cuts and I'm like,
whoa.
I think the problem is that Youtube's
algorithm favors lots like daily or even
more than daily uploads of basically to
succeed on Youtube in this environment
you have to post like every day and fan
engagement.
Yeah,
and that is kind of like crazy terms.
That's just like what's on top right now
because it's what youtube is selected
probably inadvertently to dominate.
Right.
And it's not that,
it's not that there shouldn't be that.
I mean there are people yourself
included who are very good at commentary
who should be posting a lot,
but that should be one part of an
ecosystem.
I'm saying in theory this thing is just
a blank medium,
right?
Where anything can post where anything
can.
I would just,
I just remembered in 2006 being like,
Oh man,
I wonder what youtube is going to be
like in 10 years.
It's going to be like all the Oscar
winning shorts are,
I mean,
who cares?
It doesn't matter if it's not the
Oscars,
but I'm just saying it's going be like
people are going to be uploading,
you know,
like what,
when I made my special,
I made this big thing of like,
I'm going to post it for free on
youtube,
you know,
and then give it to Netflix.
But I took way less of a pay so I could
post referring on Youtube and I posted
it for free on youtube.
But I realized like the environment had
changed so much that like,
uh,
no one even thought I was posting.
They just thought it was like a rip
from Netflix.
And I was like,
Oh man,
this place doesn't even exist for that
anymore.
Really?
That's true.
And then you see fucking,
I mean,
I don't know.
So I'm sure there's some really good
stuff.
I don't want to be shitting on people.
I'm like,
these are things I struggle with.
These are pressures,
pressures,
I feel.
Um,
but it's like,
I don't know,
around town,
I see billboards for youtube red.
And I'm like,
it looks like a Disney channel.
Like isn't this place the wild west?
Isn't this like totally free?
Why are we imposing like wire and it
feels like creators themselves are
inviting like the archaic standards of
Hollywood to themselves.
It's like you can be so much freer than
this,
I would think.
Why?
Why you making?
Do you know what I mean?
I don't think that,
well,
if you look at someone like filthy
frank,
I don't know if here that know who that
he was someone who kind of embodied what
you're talking about where he was very
much his own man.
He very much did his own thing,
didn't conform to any anything.
It was just totally fucking nuts and
everybody loved it.
But the problem was that he was always
being demonetized.
Youtube was always fucking with his
videos and in a way that didn't really
make it sustainable.
I used to love shoe.
Nice.
Who like use your nice drink glue.
It was hold a,
what did you say to shoot and I says
he's a legend.
Legend.
He called Isla and Israeli con once and
they wanted to kill her or something.
But I was like,
oh nice.
We still had in my head,
I still,
me and my girlfriend,
we always said thank yeah that,
oh he's the greatest isn't it?
But it just like,
yeah,
but you and I says he's not killing it
anymore.
Well he's killing,
well he is living,
he's killed but not,
but like I'm just saying it should be
weirder.
Right.
I that that that's all I just mean it
should be like,
but I'm glad he said bell works because
that does kind of our works and and,
and you know what?
I know that there's like hundreds of
them,
thousands of the just the system isn't
in place too.
I'm saying like what I'm saying really
is not going after the people making
stuff and even the people making stuff
would be so much better if the,
if the medium itself was encouraging
actual creative expression.
I wish they had a department or some
kind of dedication to doing that.
But as far as I'm aware,
they're just,
they don't,
and it's value.
Why are a bunch of NBC executives like
the people that work at youtube or like
a bunch of fucking dusty.
Yeah.
I shouldn't be saying this shit,
but whatever,
whatever.
I'm friends with them.
They know,
they know.
We all hate him.
All right.
I live with that.
Yeah.
It's like when you walk into Youtube
headquarters and you're like,
is this the m and m store?
Where the fuck Emma me,
me and it's like,
I don't know.
The Internet to me is like dirty and
weird and crazy and like so human.
And if you did it just scratch past the
surface,
you fall in that side.
Part of the problem that's happening is
that like with net neutrality and all,
all this stuff going on is that people
don't want the Internet to be that
dirty,
crusty place anymore.
They want it to be,
you know,
buttoned up and they want it to be
predictable and they want it to be a not
just another thing.
Yeah.
I mean that's,
that's where the movement is,
is going.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's hard because I'm on both sides a
little bit.
Cause I also look at the Internet and
don't go like the only problem with the
Internet isn't that it needs to be
freer.
You know what I mean?
There,
I mean,
there is also crazy,
you know,
I don't know if any of us should be able
to watch like people blow their heads
off,
you know what I mean?
And stuff like I don't know if but,
but,
or worse.
Yeah.
Blow,
they're much,
much worse things on the Internet.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I got you.
The snakes.
Yes.
And you know what I'm talking about.
Yeah.
Well what,
what do you think of,
um,
when you came up on youtube,
there wasn't such a notion as,
as Internet celebrity or youtube.
So,
no,
when there wasn't a standard,
there wasn't like a thing you should be,
there wasn't like a,
uh,
there wasn't a format,
so it was just like people just doing
random shit,
unpolished,
which is cool,
you know,
as opposed to like,
if you want to,
you know,
I,
I dunno,
what do you like,
what do you think?
The old dude.
But no,
but I am I,
yeah,
but I am,
I am across the old due to the,
I mean I was in 2006 right when this
thing started,
but it's because I care about it so much
and I want,
you know,
young people that are taking risks and
making interesting things to like have a
s and it's,
I say this because I care about it
because like every other medium has no
fucking chance of being cool.
Really like,
yeah,
this is like the first like real medium
where like everyone can actually access
it and like the viral,
even the idea of viral is,
is uh,
is a problem cause it,
cause it immediately puts the idea that
the only things worthy are the ones that
are,
that are um,
being seen like a million times.
You've got to find really cool channels
with like 3000 views where it's some
person giving advice or some person
teaching piano and like,
you know,
well originally that's why youtube was
all about was just a dude who wanted to
make shit and share it with like their
friends.
I mean,
that's why people made videos and the
early days before you got paid for it.
But now it's like,
I think 95% of kids,
if you ask them what's their dream job
is to be a youtuber.
Yeah.
I find that pretty strange,
Huh?
When I was a kid,
people want it to be astronauts.
Will you tubers weird?
Cause it feels like it's like movie or
no,
I guess that would just be like moving,
but youtube or it's weird that when you
say youtube or that should have no
meaning,
right.
That should actually be like something
less diverse amount should be writers.
So it was like,
oh,
what do you want to write?
But when you say youtube or it's like,
oh,
that means like Hawkeye image.
Hey,
like this for that.
You know that that's very true.
But I don't think that's true,
but I don't think it actually is true.
It just,
um,
I do think will be your neighbors that
are getting attention.
Yeah.
That is what they mean.
No,
we're all fucking losers.
I feel like that all the time.
But I know what you mean.
I love Youtube.
I love so of what it was.
Yeah.
I mean what it is and like I get,
I watch it.
I like it.
So I'm saying if kids are happy and
everyone's happy doing this shit and
people are happy watching it,
that's like totally cool.
Um,
and,
and I need to emphasize it like the real
thing I'm pissed about is not that
popular.
Youtube creators are taking this space
from these kids.
The real thing are the movie studios,
the movie trailers,
the tonight show clips that like that is
the most infuriating thing when you see
like,
um,
I thought that uh,
Shane Dawson,
Tana con thing was awesome.
It was so cool that that was incredible.
And like what an incredible thing to do.
Like form breaking any,
it was so good.
Like I was blown away and it was,
it was part and,
and because of like Shane's personal
relationship with his odd,
it was that much more meaningful.
So it's like a great like version of
that,
like a Louis throw weird version.
So that was awesome.
Yeah.
So I know people are doing that.
I just want to be like,
you know,
like I dunno like Kevin Hart doing like
vanity fairs and you know,
most viral questions,
whatever.
You know what I mean?
It's tough and all the,
no hate to any specific people.
I'm just saying like,
I know I can't believe it.
We're,
I can't believe it.
Like they do it.
These people sit in a room and they go
like,
how can we make something viral?
And they make it and it goes viral
because they called it viral in their
headline.
Why don't you like he said,
I don't think that means anything
anymore.
Like viral.
And it was just back in the day,
it was like there's a viral video,
Yodel bowl,
and it was,
it was a double rainbow.
You know what I mean?
Like that's a viral video.
It's a guy fucking tripping balls over a
cup.
I mean that's,
you know,
I don't think he's tripping balls.
I think he's just deeply that that guy
was a trip to the ball.
Is that right?
I personally think,
and this is a time time old who goes the
dynamite boom,
probably the best of all time,
one of the best of all time.
And like it's similar with the movie,
which is like cringe means a lot to me.
You know what I mean?
Like,
and there's some like I love like,
and like our cringe and that all that
stuff is,
it gets a little dark.
I don't know why the cringe communities
sometimes can be very mean,
but I like all the videos but I,
I re they're like deeply beautiful to
me.
They're deeply vulnerable and wonderful
and meaningful.
Tristan,
I'm saying like some people would watch
the,
that weird hot dog video,
the guy blending the things and want to
like tell him to kill himself or
whatever.
But I think it's like just so beautiful
that we have access to people's most
mortifying moments and I feel for them
and I think cringing is a form of
empathy and you know,
well certainly it is.
You're,
you're embarrassed for them.
Yeah.
So like,
and it's,
and it's vulnerable and like that boom
goes the dynamite.
I think that's,
that is me on stage if I just wasn't as
good or what an r or not,
you know,
if I was,
that is what it was happening for me.
It's that I could just power through it.
He's like having a panic attack and
Reggie Miller is looking good.
Reggie Miller is the best shit ever.
Later he gets the rebound passed it to
the man.
Well,
speaking of viral
videos,
I mean you mentioned,
you mentioned the hot dog peach.
Ian Found it now first of all,
this video,
this is a [inaudible] because I guess he
erased it.
It was too,
uh,
too wild for this world.
Yeah.
But this has a 200,000
views,
so we are really,
this guy is kind of has a little bit of
a fan base.
Yeah.
Wow.
So anyone can make it.
Yeah.
See everybody.
It's so funny,
after the conversation we had,
it's going to act like I want more of
this,
which is just like,
man,
we need more of this.
Yeah.
Let's see.
Do you know who were,
where he,
this guy is?
He's in his kitchen or I mean like,
okay,
I wonder what was the impulse?
This guy had to be like,
I want to share this.
But that's true.
What is,
no,
but that's beautiful,
right Jimmy?
So this guy lives is,
I mean,
but he's not even taking inventory of
what's in his house,
but he's making the video of the,
as the,
as if this is normal and as if people
want to learn how to make hot dogs and
peaches.
I mean,
but really is in a bathroom.
No,
but this is truly beautiful and so
deeply sad and funny and tragic.
So we're learning about his life,
seeing all these,
oh,
so the sausages or just actual fucking
hot dogs.
I love that he calls it sausage.
She's feeling a little bourgeois today,
but sees reaching for something,
but he wants to teach us.
He,
yeah,
he wants to share.
It's beautiful.
As beautiful.
He's like,
you know what?
Basically what it implies is that it
took me a lot to be able to learn.
I've learned the skill of cooking these
hot dogs.
Yeah.
And I think there's a sausage.
Sorry.
Don't mean to downplay the Karmanos of
it and he,
and he's blending peaches.
But basically I found this secret,
this wonderful looking at cooking it.
I'm sorry.
Oh,
I miss,
I uh,
does that,
I don't know if that just a little zap.
Okay.
What I'm saying it is an event.
I mean,
it's different.
He's like,
I found this new way to do this.
You guys,
it's,
but it's like,
I don't,
I can't explain it.
This means a lot to me.
This is beautiful.
And why have I not seen this?
This is really something.
Why have I seen this?
That's the real question.
This is,
this sounds like it's right up your acts
of salsa.
Let me,
but I'm saying this is a glimpse into a
life we never would have without this.
Right.
Pray to God.
You never have a glimpse into this life.
Right.
Um,
but,
but not that.
Not that we're just seeing it.
We're seeing it through his pov.
Yes.
And like with his perspective,
with his wants,
it's incredible.
It's,
to me,
it's so cinematic and increase.
It's like some crazy beautiful,
like harmony corrine.
Like here,
let me crank the volume.
Actually want to watch this.
It's eight minutes.
So it's a lot.
It's a lot.
Yeah.
That makes gimme this cat is,
he gonna throw those dogs in the blender
with the peaches.
Oh my God.
It's healthy in a way.
He's like,
listen,
a little protein.
A little fiber.
Yeah,
it's a balanced meal.
Okay,
let's skip forward it to them.
To the fucking,
he had one at one point,
washes the thing in the sink,
but the dog,
he watches the dog and you got an,
you got to rinse the dog's clothes.
Look at the trash and the ground and
look at,
he just really tossed that in there in a
way that quite never.
It's got a little Amarillo going on.
A little.
Yeah.
Oh,
why is it,
why is there,
why is there a toilet there?
I don't understand the toilet.
His,
his,
his accident is also like in placeable.
Really?
Unplaceable so let's cut to the,
uh,
the big moment.
If you're worried,
this is an exciting for the audience.
Trust me,
it is.
It's just sad.
See,
now he's living,
he's look,
look,
go.
Whoa.
That looks like started the fucking,
he started the wrong,
his post place was just about to burn
down.
Yeah.
Cause he started the wrong,
because he was overreaching.
He probably hasn't done this before.
Oh,
you think this is a new recipe?
But he's,
nobody's trying to act like he's didn't
Tostito's man,
I've noticed.
Oh yeah.
It's brand loyal.
Just saying,
but wouldn't the world be a better place
if we watched this with love?
Am I insane?
No,
you're not at saying,
I mean,
I think people do,
but also people are too.
You have to have a certain level of
maturity to be like,
I love this guy and not be like,
this guy's a fucking loser.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think most people probably over the
age of 20 or like having sympathy or
repulsed in just whatever.
Yeah.
Listen,
don't want,
well,
let's go.
Let's get to the fireworks.
Yup.
Let's get them.
Let's get to,
I'm trying it,
which is that towards the end
we're looking at,
oh my God,
he's nervous.
He's like,
ah,
you did double the cups up if you
notice.
So he,
uh,
he's uh,
by you hip hop artist,
right?
Well,
yeah,
he doubled up.
I think he just cherishes the content so
much,
you know,
link.
He does not lose the drop.
So am I correct me if I'm wrong?
He didn't blend the dogs.
He sliced them little bites and not,
well he did he blend it and put it into
the already blended peaches?
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm just trying to get the recipe
straight.
So if I'm gonna get this at home,
either course cleanups,
a breeze.
You just leave everything there for 10
years.
Huh?
Seriously.
Hold on.
I'm suspicious of this.
Can I say that?
Okay.
But in what way?
I think it's might be an art piece.
Oh,
it's an art piece.
But regardless,
I don't think this guy is real.
I think he might be an actor.
No,
no,
no.
You know what I'm saying?
Way Too.
Specifical good way to spin.
He hates it.
He pours it out and yet still uploads
it.
Let's see.
Now you're getting now.
Now you're getting it.
No,
but it that they're all,
they're all like,
I can show you a video of a nine year
old that has a claw machine in his house
cause his mother like s like put a
reverse mortgage on her house to buy him
a claw machine that also looks like an
art piece.
I believe this that they're like Ian,
pull that up.
That's really going to be hard to find.
That was like super,
but like it's like claw machine.
Boy.
I guess this is just that this,
I mean I'm not saying that it's for sure
fake,
but I'm still skeptical.
The thing is this predates kind of the
era.
I'm so skeptical of everything I see on
the Internet to the point where I'm
like,
I don't know that this is real.
Of course.
No,
no,
there's,
what do they do?
Bring all the fucking shit under there.
Why not?
It's just a,
why is there a toilet in the bowl?
Why is there a toilet in the room?
He said no,
he goes to the bathroom.
Why is he cooks in the bathroom?
Yeah.
Where does he live?
Does he live in the bathroom?
Okay.
You got to just take the whole thing as
a package.
You can pick and choose,
but that's,
I just,
I'm just saying I have,
I've seen red flag.
He's,
okay.
So he's cooking.
He's hot dogs and peaches.
And you're confused that he's going to
the bathroom to get the water?
No,
but it's also perfect.
It wouldn't be that hard to throw some
tostitos and aback and bathroom right
out.
I mean,
either way I listen.
I don't,
I don't want to take,
I think it's real.
You don't have to know.
I like of all the conspiracies I've had
to walk people through,
you know,
I'm a much happier to do this then like
the moon,
Israel.
I think the moon's real as far as I,
a friend does not think the moon is
real.
You have a moon Downer.
Deeply deep.
He would,
he would draw drawed.
My friend drawn Carmichael,
who I did special for your trail.
He's very,
um,
well,
what's the story about the mountain?
Not that it's not real or does he
actually think it's like a Hologram?
Oh No,
no.
They'll going to the moon never
happened.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that'd be done.
No,
no.
They're going to the moon in that.
How do you still believe that in this
day and age?
That really blows my mind.
He can make a good case.
Really?
You want to try to convince me he would
do a good job?
I don't believe it,
but,
but um,
the Moana is fake,
ladies and gentlemen.
You heard it.
The moon.
It's doesn't exist at all.
All right,
well
I do want to see how this ends.
If I can be frank with you.
I mean,
it looks very real.
Everything okay?
If it's fake,
it's the greatest production designer of
all time.
Right?
Like it's beautifully put together.
That's true.
This guy would be going places right now
if he would be like,
it just,
it just like incredibly up the flat,
the two flashlights.
Are you kidding me?
That's incredible detail.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh,
he's,
no,
he's not American.
You know that,
right?
He sounds like Scandinavian or
something.
Speaking English was,
you hear that?
He said I hadn't caught that before and
abandoned for a couple of days.
Go back.
Let's put the pieces together.
This might be,
yeah.
Oh,
what?
That's weird.
What is his house like?
Where if this is where he goes to cook,
why does and why would a guy like this
have like,
uh,
another,
he's got two houses on it.
I'd like to think he's like,
yeah,
he was my assistant multimillionaire
with like a bun,
like 15,
just shit holes.
This is real by the way.
That,
but that detail like you could never,
you can never write it.
You could never write it.
Yeah.
Stranger than fiction as they say.
What is niceness?
Is this fuck with you?
This is us right now.
Okay.
You want to click it?
Let's see.
Is this weird?
Wow.
This is us live right now.
I hate it.
And then,
no,
no.
You have to,
well you have to wait until we opened us
live.
Okay.
Here,
let me mute it so that at least that,
no,
no.
You have to like yell.
But then it's like,
it's so bad cause they hear us through
the laptop and it was just repetitive.
I made that mistake before.
Okay.
This is so weird that like,
God,
yeah,
this is too mad at,
this is a,
this is a panic attack right now
basically.
Yeah.
This is what it feels like.
This is,
I'm having a panic attack right now.
Okay.
All right.
We've,
we've,
oh,
that's a good dude.
It's awesome.
Wait,
can we get more meadow with it?
Well,
I just,
we just cut to the wide,
so in a moment it's going okay.
Good names within dreams.
Within dreams.
Have you seen the lights,
camera,
Jackson's interstellar review reviews of
all time?
By the way,
I just want to say,
okay,
that,
um,
uh,
eighth grade,
the reviews keep going up during the
break.
They're like rotten tomatoes up.
It's at a 99.9
and to do points.
Yeah,
no,
it's at 99.9
and it's like,
as you can get all like b minuses and
still have 100% well that's fine.
I mean,
it's still a good measurement.
It's like yes or no.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Yes.
And it's an emphatic,
we all loved this peaches or sausages
and we got all peaches baby.
It's all peaches here by all features
today.
Um,
how do we,
where do we go from there?
Um,
I got some other stuff we could talk
about what you want,
man.
Um,
a lot of bullshit,
Yada,
Yada.
Oh,
here's something I do.
I do.
Oh,
I got a button that does that.
Okay.
Pretty cool.
Um,
I saw you on the Green Room when you sat
with all those Comedians,
whatever.
And you were the young guy and they were
all like,
look at this young guy,
whatever.
But there was one detail about that.
You don't wanna talk about it.
It was fine.
It was being an asshole.
Well,
anyway,
I don't,
I'm,
I love Gary shandling.
He's like,
I have totally the bad news for you.
Yeah.
Wait,
what is it?
He's fine.
He's living happily did.
Yeah.
Yes.
Rest in peace.
He would have liked that.
Maybe the cellar doors slammed.
I do know he's passed.
So like,
but I love so much this moment there
when they introduced you and you're
like,
Hey,
I'm from the new generation and I,
and I was just wondering who are you
guys?
And I could tell a lot of them were,
were rubbed the wrong way by that.
A lot of the guys were like,
specifically I thought like Mark Marin
was like,
look at this fucking kid,
you know?
Yeah.
But whatever.
But then garry shandling came out with
this beautiful response of like,
well that's so great that you say that
because the feeling so mutual.
Yeah.
It was perfect.
But not only was he perfectly funny,
I feel like you,
you weren't dear to him and that
throughout the rest of it he was very
supportive and very accepting of you and
just really a sweetheart.
Yeah.
And I was,
I'm just wondering if you had any other
interactions with them.
Yeah,
I sort of had a relationship with them
going forward.
Like,
um,
that's what we like go over.
Yeah.
You play ball with him.
I didn't,
it was more just one on one,
just going over there on weekends and
like sitting with him for a while and he
actually read the script of this movie
is where the first really?
Yeah.
Wow.
He's just super nice and super deep and
kind and just as smart,
just a deep kind person,
which are just very cool and very like
patient and open.
Um,
but yeah,
there's nothing worse than five
comedians sitting around performing.
I mean,
it's so fucking,
I don't know that,
not that I ever being just mean like
everyone tried to outdo each other.
It's,
so,
I feel like that situation was something
that I would hate to ever be involved
in,
just cause it's like so competitive.
It has to be.
Otherwise you just,
if you don't want to compete to like
prove how funny or witty you are,
you just sit there like a fucking idiot
doing bits in life.
It gets very,
very exhausting.
Um,
but that was a,
that was actually kind of a fun one
because I was so young and it was just
like,
so different than it felt like we could
all just sorta fuck with each other a
little bit.
But,
you know,
um,
get Gary's dude.
Good Dude.
I love him.
I mean,
well,
okay.
I don't.
Okay,
cool.
We talked about that.
Yeah.
Great.
He's a very zen eastern now he's such a
Buddhist guy and like are you into that
shit?
I wish I was.
You feel like you could be and I wish I
was.
Yeah,
I keep trying,
but then I never do like I bought a
bunch of books and I'm like,
I'll read those some day.
Yeah.
But as they say,
it's in the buying that the,
as they say,
you just like put the verb first and you
let the books in your shelf and they
will by proximity man,
who's stands lesson toilet get high on
pot.
Yeah.
Right.
Um,
that was much better than one.
I said.
What was yours?
It really didn't go anywhere at all.
I don't know.
I was a fifth grade thing I heard.
Um,
yeah.
Anyway.
Are you,
are you Buddhist?
Are you into all of that,
that you stern stuff?
I'm more into the idea of religion than
I was as a cool ass 19 year old atheist.
You have come around not around.
I just like,
I don't really hold like it takes up so
little of my mind criticizing it or no,
you,
you like felt,
you felt when you were younger that need
to be like,
God dude.
And now I'm like,
ah,
I mean whatever you get through the
moment.
I feel the same exact way.
There's something about when you're
young and you're like,
I'm fucking so smart.
I get this shit 80 it's like you think
there's a guy in the sky?
Yeah.
It's like there are people a lot smarter
than you that are religious so it isn't
inherently a dumb idea.
So it's like,
what do you understand about the
university little fucking idiot?
What do you understand about your own
head?
Yeah,
I mean like,
like that's the thing is that like the
subjective experience.
It's so mind blowingly impossible to
understand that.
Sure.
God,
you know what I mean?
Like I don't do that.
We're any of any of this is happening.
God weirder than like anything that just
existing,
I don't believe in God necessarily,
but I don't not believe in God.
I believe in buying books about Buddhism
and putting on my bookshelf.
Yeah.
Well we,
we,
we pray to the god of brick and mortar.
Yeah.
Um,
did you go to a brick and mortar?
Was it online?
Online?
Come on.
I'm a home.
Homesman exactly.
You think I'd show up around a book
store.
Have you,
when's the last time you went to a
bookstore?
I go to bookstores.
I like to walk around a bookstore.
Nice mom and pop shop like an Amazon
books.
You know,
the Amazon makes bookstores.
Those are great.
Real down to earth.
Are you serious?
Yeah.
They have bookstore.
They went and like just did you not have
enough of the market?
But they literally true.
They literally destroyed bookstores and
then like down and they're basically
dancing the absolutely.
No,
no,
no.
They're like fucking their wives on
their graves.
I'm moving next door to like,
Jeff's book starts like this just old
fucking place.
Yeah.
Um,
Amazon bookstores.
I go to churches to,
when I'm in the city,
I'll go to a church and sit down.
You'll sit down through the thing
usually like on off hours because it's
like,
why do you go there?
Do you pray?
I'll see.
Contemplating.
Yeah.
You find that the environment does
something quiet.
Well,
the church I've been to churches and
cathedrals and there's definitely a
vibe,
you know,
it's great.
It's like,
and like you really can't be on your
phone when you're in there.
It's not even about God.
It's almost just about like the
quietness of like just being,
there is something divine in existence.
Let's just say agree we don't agree on,
but let's just say I think that,
but
like you really feel that there and it's
like you don't have to believe in Jesus
Christ.
You don't have to look at a guy in a
cross,
but there's something divine about being
alive and you feel that there.
And like silence is as valuable as its
ever been.
Like silent attention is like so rare to
get a less stimulation.
Um,
can I go to a church?
I'm Jewish by gorgeous ethnicity.
Yeah.
If you don't mind,
you're not going to help me out and can
be like,
somebody is not gonna be like you look a
little Jewish.
Can I see your id?
Uh,
he wouldn't say a little strange.
Well he wouldn't come out that.
So we've got,
um,
uh,
thank you by the way.
If you're cool with,
you know,
I think you might,
I can't go to a synagogue.
Hell yeah.
Where I belong.
Yeah.
It's party there.
Um,
but yeah,
church is for everybody.
I didn't know that.
I think so.
Is that what they say?
No,
but no,
no.
I think a lot of them,
I like,
my mom goes to like a Presbyterian
whatever and the,
the guy was like,
anyone's welcome at this table if you're
trans,
if you're this,
if it was like things are changing,
things are changing.
Can I talk about your mom?
You have,
your mom has a really interesting
vocation.
She a hospice nurse.
Yeah.
She'd been doing hospice.
I mean stupid boss diminishes,
which is basically she takes care of end
of life.
Yeah.
And she works in a hospice center.
So a lot of hospice nurses are out of
how,
you know,
they'll go to,
they'll go to a dying patient in their
house,
but the,
this is where dying patients come and
it's end of life care.
So the average day is two weeks,
no one recovers.
You know when you go there you do not
leave.
They are,
see she sees three or four deaths a day.
What is it,
I'm curious just systematically how
people end up there.
Is it like a health insurance thing?
Is it like a government thing?
Um,
that's a great question.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's when the dying process starts,
I mean it's when the illness is fully
move Oli terminal moving out of the
hospital and into,
into a place where it's called end of
life care,
where you're just trying to make them
uncomfortable and think about how that
came into exist.
Is it part of the hospital?
Like who runs that?
I have no idea.
I don't,
that's Kinda like where did that come
from?
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Um Huh.
Cause most hospice is the specific out
of institute.
Like,
it's actually just nurses going to take
care of you at home,
so you're tying in your home.
Um,
this sort of thing.
A hospice center is much,
much rare,
but no,
it's a lot of donations and things.
I mean like it's not just,
you know,
like a for profit place.
Um,
but yeah,
it's pretty cool.
How was that like,
I mean,
affected her and maybe even you by
proxy,
I mean surely that trickles down to you
too as well.
Yeah.
I mean she's doing it nine or 10 years
now and um,
it's insane.
You know,
she,
she have,
after the first two weeks of working
there,
she forgot the president's name,
so she went to the hospital to get a cat
scan because she thought she had a brain
tumor and she went to work the next day
and her boss said,
that just happens here and you just
forget you,
you're just going to be blocking so much
of what's happening out here that it's
con like that.
He's like,
Oh,
if you only told me,
I would've told you that that happens to
everybody here.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
And like when she was getting ready to
interview for the place,
she saw like a body getting carried out.
Like,
I can't fucking do this.
And then two weeks in she's carrying a
body out,
chatting with the nurse's assistant,
puts in the car and turns around and
it's like,
whoa,
crazy.
And I'll be with her.
Like a diner in a family will come up
and be like,
Patty,
oh my God.
Like,
you know,
cause she saw her,
they're,
you know,
father through his last two weeks of his
life and they'll leave and she'll go,
I don't remember them.
It's like the most,
she'll be some like the most important
people in some people's lives for,
you know,
five of them a day.
And it's like,
man,
how does that affect her?
It has their personality changes.
She's incredibly stable and like it,
it's all women.
You know,
it's like mostly all women there.
And it's like,
uh,
it's like a really incredible example of
like the sort of condescended
stereotyped quality of,
of women of like,
Oh yeah,
women are maternal and women are very
caring,
but it's like a,
a like military,
like as as tough a version of that is
can be,
and you actually realize that like
caring is actually,
is actually the most tough and resilient
thing you can actually do at its extreme
that I'm saying people come back from
war,
you know,
unable to fucking process thoughts.
My mother comes back from watching like
a 40,
40 year old bleed out in front of his
family and she comes to like,
you know,
smiles and cooks us dinner.
You know,
like that is,
that is actual strength,
you know,
and it,
and it is,
um,
yeah,
she's wild,
wild stories.
Wild that is,
you know,
people dying of alcoholism and she will
dip a qtip and Jack Daniels and swab it
and their mouth.
Wow.
You know,
cause it's just,
it's just people dying of lung cancer.
She takes them out,
she wields it out into the snow and
holds a cigarette to their lips because
they're two weeks.
Eh,
you know,
cause it's just end of life care.
It's not about they're venting and it's
also very medical.
She's also like a nurse practitioner.
I mean she's a,
she knows what she's worked in the Er,
she's done these things.
So,
but um,
yeah,
it's wild.
You know,
that's gotta be one of the craziest
fucking jobs you can possibly be for
family members showing up.
Like threatening to fucking kill people.
Like get my dad out of here.
You shouldn't be what?
I mean like,
oh fucking not adding to terms with it
or like they don't want them here or
they're confused or they're,
you know,
it's,
well I can say just from like my wife
Isla is going through something with her
dad right now and like just hearing her
talking about it is like,
it's so,
it's just so fucked up.
Like we're so bad at dealing with death,
we don't think about it until it's
there.
And so like these women,
these nurses that are,
that are,
were,
are like such rocks for people because
my mother will sit there and go like,
she knows how to deal with it and she
knows what it looks like.
Like everybody,
she knows how to deal with it and it's,
and dealing with it as in like they make
it easier.
But she,
she'll,
she,
she can say like,
she's never seen last words in her life
ever.
She says they almost,
they almost never speak for the last two
hours.
There is a last breath,
but there's almost never a last word.
It's like really,
really incredibly,
incredibly fast.
She was on an episode of,
cause I talked a little bit about this
on Marin's podcast like a long time ago
and uh,
Nancy Updike from this American life
herd and they did it this American life.
And on my ma,
half of it's on my mom and you can hear
her in the hospice center.
It's,
it's like,
and some people,
you know,
it sucks for her because it's such an
interesting job and of course it is
emotionally taxing and she needs to talk
about it,
but it's like,
it's such a hard thing to talk about
because people care about and they go
like,
I just can't fucking hear that.
But it definitely puts,
it puts my job in a perspective very
easily.
Yeah.
Do you mean where I can just be like,
oh,
who gives a shit?
What happens with,
you know,
this thing or that like,
I just,
I wonder if like we as a society and
this kind of a fucking ridiculous
question out there,
but like if we just dealt with death
better,
you know what I mean?
Like it's just,
it's this buggy.
We all obviously know we're going to
die.
But like the thought of it,
the prepping of it,
the Association of it,
the way that,
like we prolonging it,
even when it's over like this,
this is what this is,
is that when people are dying and
they're on death's bed certain to die
and they're suffering,
there's no quality of life.
And,
um,
the family suffering,
the person suffering,
it's like you prolonged that for as long
as possible.
I don't understand that.
Yeah.
I think we've done better with grief
than we have death.
You know what I mean?
We,
we,
like,
there's,
there's more of an infrastructure for
the grieving process,
you know,
I think,
um,
like we're,
we're more familiar with that.
I'm saying before,
we may,
like,
we've experienced funerals,
we know what that is,
we know that space a little bit.
Those are very public and right.
Yeah.
But the dying process for people
unfamiliar with it is intense.
And my grandfather,
my father's father died at the hospice
center my mom was working at,
but she couldn't work with him because
they don't let you work.
Conflict of interest.
Yeah.
Well the,
the,
there's interest,
but like,
yeah,
just like fucked up.
It's,
uh,
it's like,
it just wouldn't be healthy or
something.
Yeah.
And that,
I mean,
but yeah,
like my mother will come home like
having a rough day and it's like,
what was it?
It's like,
yeah,
it was a young person,
you know,
it's like fucking ends.
And it's in Massachusetts in like this
beautiful,
weird,
centered,
all of these windows.
And like the seasons are changing and
it's like,
I would love to make a movie about it.
It's just like a little too crazy and
heavy.
This subject matters is very interesting
and I think it's something that really
should be explored honestly.
It's like,
I wonder if there's a way to make it
that isn't brutally depressing.
You know what I mean?
I know.
I don't think there is,
but could be beautifully depressing
maybe.
But like there's one story that she told
me this like incredible.
Um,
one of her nurses aids,
um,
lots of immigrants that,
that work there.
And she,
she was a Haitian immigrant and she was
in the room holding something in her
arms,
in a towel.
And My mother was working with,
uh,
older gentleman who was very sick and
sort of out of it.
And My mother was like,
um,
so she's going to take care of you now.
And the old guy said some racial slur,
you know,
this is a black woman.
And it says like,
I don't want that whatever touching me
or getting near me.
And mother turns to the nurse and she's
like,
you know,
putting this stuff into him that like
cox and out for a little bit so they can
like change his bedding and everything.
And my mom turns to the nurse's aide and
like,
you don't have to do this.
Like he said,
that's really inappropriate.
You know,
I'll do this,
don't worry.
And she's going,
no,
no holding singling.
No,
no,
it's okay.
It's okay.
Okay.
Like hearing all this and my mother
watches is the guy I'm like dozes off
for a bit and the woman opens the towel
and she'd been warming lotion while he's
saying all this stuff to her.
She was warming lotion for him and she's
passed out sports and it gives him like,
like works into his feet and his hands.
That's after hearing her compassion.
I,
it's like incredible.
It's like,
you know,
the,
the people that do this are like true,
truly angels and they're angels.
And then you,
I go to,
you know,
I go to the hospice center all the time
to check in and,
you know,
seeing my mom and it's like a bunch of,
little Boston ladies being like,
Oh,
ball,
you're out in the Hollywood.
Oh my God,
can we get,
you know what I mean?
They're like little,
it's incredible.
It's,
it's a,
it's,
it's a crazy little world.
There,
there was,
I think it was an hbo show about it.
Um,
I never saw it,
but moving,
I would definitely love to watch
anything about that.
It's just,
I think a documentary,
I'd be the best.
I mean,
I you,
the respect of the family makes it
because you couldn't really do it,
but I,
right.
That you should listen to.
It's called death and taxes.
The,
this American life.
I'll check it.
Pretty incredible.
Love it.
Love that show.
Um,
well thanks for sharing that.
Yeah.
Do you,
well,
let's,
so let's switch gear and please,
um,
you know,
I used to do this thing at the end of
our show.
We used to ask people if that goes
stories.
But frankly I don't,
I'd rather do something else with you.
Okay.
Can I,
yeah,
I don't,
I didn't think you would.
And I frankly don't either.
I don't even know why it's still going
on.
It's like,
do you have ghost stories?
They're like,
no.
It was like,
yeah,
I don't either.
Like our fans got into this thing about
ghost stories and I'm like,
I don't,
I don't believe in ghosts.
You guys,
regardless,
I'm want to do a new thing,
which is that I've werewolf stories.
Um,
I find the perfect video to watch with
my guest.
Hell yeah.
To close up the show.
And I think I found the perfect video to
watch with the,
okay.
So first of all,
let me hit you with one of these.
Okay.
Now Bo in the house
is a origin meme.
It's kind of one of our earliest and
best music,
I would say in reaction to one of the
best videos on the Internet.
Um,
it's Papa John.
Yeah,
I actually do remember this.
You know the Papa John's do.
I do remember that.
This is the tour of his house,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I haven't seen this a little,
so I thought we'd watch it together.
Know I do have the name of some like
asshole.
You mean like some asshole kid?
Well,
there was no like you saw Chris Southern
quarter ballot be oh,
oh,
he's being,
you know how this motherfucker's spells
his name?
You do.
You just said it.
I was like that.
My French fucking bright.
Yeah,
no,
no.
Yeah,
of course not.
I feel bad for him in a way though.
He probably got his ass beat in high
school though.
Oh,
well the good thing.
Well,
it's not like we're bringing them up and
eat again to be shamed publicly in front
of thousands.
Well,
he's just,
he's grown up.
He's come to terms with the pizza man.
His Dad is kind of taking the heat off
him.
Like I say that his dad is,
I like it was on a conference call.
Yeah,
he dropped the n bomb pop.
It doesn't have the best track record.
Yeah.
So hoppa John,
man,
I love Papa John.
He's like,
he's just got so high curls.
Oh,
we got that hot,
luxurious by,
you know what I always say about Papa
John?
He looks like a hammerhead shark.
He,
nope.
That's not what I say,
but I like it.
It looks like he's too close to a pizza
oven for too long,
because you know what I mean?
Like let's pull up a zap of Papa John
here.
Let's give you guys the whole lore
overview before we,
before we dive in head first year.
No,
I don't want Google to know my fucking
location.
He always looks a little wet.
That is what I mean.
Like the cheese is melted on his face.
Yeah.
He looks like that pizza is a little
overcooked.
You know what I'm saying?
Right.
Yeah.
He looks like just,
it's not,
it looks like he's own wax sculpture.
That's right.
That's,
that's a good way to put it.
He's clearly had some work,
but man,
nothing can fix man.
That left eye is nothing.
Trying to look at someone else.
Nothing could have fixed.
Look at those brows,
Bro.
Couple pepperoni's look at this.
Danny Zuko Curley's trying to rock up
top and like,
I mean that like,
I will say to his credit,
he's an incredible,
he's,
he really was a guy with the pizza
joint.
The grew it out of nowhere.
Yeah.
Well you know what?
Some pizza joints got to work.
So here,
let me show you this.
I mean,
wait,
it's Papa John's the one with the garlic
sauce.
Yeah.
It's actually pretty good.
I Love Papa John's.
It started from a real place.
This whole papa bless it started from a
real place of,
of love for Boppa.
You know what I mean?
Uh,
he various shit faced.
Yeah.
I mean,
here you go.
Just get it close up.
Yeah.
He's got a real nineties magician vibe,
right?
Yeah.
Like a,
remember those shows on ABC where the
guy would wear white mask and expose all
the time.
I love that magician at home.
It'd be like,
what the fuck dude,
that was him,
the one ingredient home line.
Uh,
but what was it I wanted to show you?
Oh,
I don't know if there's so much papa
John Content does show you.
Papa is in the house.
Is Really,
they should is nuts.
Not this is like a separate computer
just for this.
Right.
I would like never broadcast my,
my,
my browser.
I was like be terrifying.
So no,
well,
yeah,
yes,
yes.
Yeah.
My related video,
you'd be like,
no,
no.
Okay.
No,
no,
no.
This is just for here baby.
I'm all good.
No history on this one.
Yeah.
It's like a destiny's child feet that
was giving.
No,
I feel you man.
I'm here.
This is the one I wanted to show you.
Just the beginning.
They staged this whole ridiculous
promotional thing and I love how he
thinks he's like a celebrity.
Like he's a pizza celebrity.
You know what I mean?
It's a shit.
Oh,
hey.
You know what though?
He's spoken into existence,
man.
Yeah.
He wanted to be committed,
became it.
He dead.
Well not probably not what he wanted,
but he did become something in the
higher they climb,
the harder they fall.
Very true.
So,
um,
anyway,
they went and set this whole thing up.
Like he's supposed to go to this
culinary school and teaching people how
to make a pizza.
But it's so obviously fake.
I mean,
but he has people,
just enjoy this.
Yeah,
everyone's got paper plates
and the host is just the most flattering
cock sucking judge Jack.
I just got this.
It's,
it's cannot be overused.
That's incredible.
All right.
I get to the fucking point.
I liked this.
I liked this part in the show or were
like already hour and a half in.
So now it's like nobody's really
watching.
Yeah.
Great.
Right.
So it's like the pressure is really off
at this point.
This guy's the c o of Secrets of
Louisville shifts.
So apparently it's pr.
It's a series
right here.
Is this not like a,
just like a fever dream does it?
It feels like Tim and Eric.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
The mural
and insane in the back.
Hold on you.
He's got a Lav and they don't mute it so
you can hear him making these really
weird sounds like he goes like,
whoa.
And Shit like that,
but we lose it.
Hey,
hmm.
Oh my God.
It was,
you know,
listen to,
this shit is incredible.
I somehow,
I've never made a video about this
because,
oh,
there's only a few wonderful moments
like this,
but the rest is just so boring.
No,
no,
it's not worth it.
No,
but this is beautiful.
And like 93,000
is truly under the radar.
Oh yeah.
Um,
I'm sure they put a lot of marketing in
this,
but here,
oh,
I need to go back one
very exciting what's going on there?
But can we stop for that?
I mean,
he is like the,
it's,
it's lesson.
He's Papa John.
Sometimes.
That's enough.
It wasn't enough.
When was,
it was yesterday and all the shit went
down,
right?
Yeah.
It's weird little fucking,
he's,
the public doesn't ask.
He does not have the best track record.
He,
he was,
when it was in the news first one,
he was like,
I'm not gonna fucking increase my pizza
prices by 1 cent to give my employees
healthcare because of obamacare.
They were like,
you've cheap fucking right John.
I mean if,
if,
if the CEO's of our pain or celebrity
ceos of our pizza chain restaurants
can't survive the current cultural
moment,
who can,
yeah.
I feel like I'm next and you know what
the thing is,
it's like what are we gonna have to get
into a fucking him or whatever,
but like we have to take him so
seriously.
Cause it's like,
it's kind of like he could be president,
so we just only like literally we have
to take them seriously.
But yeah,
we actually have to be worried about
this,
that like that's the problem with the
culture and I want to get into all that
shit you know?
Mean.
But like what's insane is that like,
ev,
the entire culture exists on the same
level and on that same plane and it,
and it mimics our fucking phones.
It's like you scroll through your
twitter and you will,
or your instagram and you will see in no
particular order,
your mother,
your friend Geico,
the president of the United States,
Kim Kardashians.
And it's like,
and that's what the national
conversation has become.
Like,
it's just all the same.
It's like when Kanye freaked out,
we have to take them seriously.
Cause like w what's the fucking
difference there?
There is only one conversation being
yeah,
you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
It's like yeah it kind of like we,
I would just be like yeah fuck this guy.
But it's like no like we have to
actually keep an eye on our pizza guys
cause they may run the fucking world.
I gets crazy.
Yeah.
No I think that's true.
Well and similarly he got in trouble
when he'd said that the NFL people and
you stop protesting because it's
affecting pizza prices.
Did you see it?
That whole thing when the kneeling nfl
player are yeah,
nfl.
And he was like listen,
I'm going to pull my sponsors.
He was like their number one sponsor and
if these guys keeping yelling because
our pizza sales are down since they
started protesting,
that's crazy.
And the kneeling thing is like I
personally am publicly have,
I've always been like what is it?
Why do you fucking care?
But also like,
don't we know that like the Department
of Defense pays like $50 million like
that?
All the flag shit is advertisements for
the military.
The Department of Defense pays the NFL
like,
Whoa,
why pay them to do this?
All the other reuniting troops and
stuff,
those are paid paid stage things too.
That's fuck.
So like,
no wonder they're angry obviously,
because like you're,
it's not that like you're kneeling
during the anthem.
It's like,
no,
you're kneeling during our ad time.
Disparaging are,
are,
no,
this is the answer.
Yeah.
No,
this is a,
we paid for this shit to be an
advertisement and your d,
that's a fucking great advertisement.
That is exactly the people that go sign
up.
Yeah.
And like,
and like chill,
whatever.
I mean,
I think it should be stated.
You mean like I'm saying,
I don't think whatever does it,
the FCC have rules.
Like I as a youtuber need to disclose
what I'm sponsored,
the military sponsor of the NFL and
nobody needs to be like,
hey,
this is a page.
This national anthem is a paid
sponsorship.
Yeah.
It's slats fucking creepy.
Crazy.
Yeah.
Um,
well,
yeah,
I mean,
oh,
well let's get them off the field.
And that case,
I didn't know they were disparaging a
sponsor.
Yeah,
exactly.
Now we got a problem.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well anyway,
can we please acknowledge the,
it's too good,
but know,
but that is truly,
that is what I searched for it.
It's like the micro moments of those
systems,
a beautiful micro moment and boom goes,
the dynamite is so good because it's
like it's one after another point that
very well,
I think it goes the dynamite did he
coined that?
I don't know.
It's his now.
I mean if he coined that then,
but that's what's so sad about is he's
flailing and then in the Lebanese it's
back to the thing that he wanted to say
if it went well,
which is going goes to nine at night.
But yeah,
it's like I said,
what do you feel for pup right now?
Do you sympathize with them?
No.
Okay.
No,
no,
no.
It's like,
try to sympathize with this man.
It's hilarious.
I just can't believe like,
I just can't believe where the headlines
look like.
Yeah.
It's like Papa John,
I'm trying to,
it's crazy droplet Papa John,
drop the n bomb on conference call with
the board of directors.
Yeah,
and you're like,
yeah and that should be funny or weird
or like I'm saying it should be like
some weird face off and not look
indistinguishable from like geopolitical
headlines.
I totally hear you.
I think it will be,
I have this problem with twitter news,
which I love twitter news.
It's almost like,
it's like a fucking ivy of all this
bullshit right into my vein.
I don't almost use twitter at all.
Just the news.
Yeah,
sometimes.
Yeah.
Album is like,
what happened was Shane Dawson,
somebody just added the blue.
Well what was it?
Then they accused him of being a
pedophile or some shit.
What was it?
But it was just like so unfounded and
they ran it as this headline and I was
like,
damn,
that shouldn't be,
you know,
like you said next to,
to the point where he said he was
getting like a cost at starbucks and
stuff.
Right.
Like just because some asshole blast it
on there.
Let's not,
let's not veer off too far,
but no,
but it's incredible to talk about the
dangers of the Internet while also
showcasing them bite during hip saying,
yeah,
I mean this thing is so fucking awesome.
Look at this.
It's got pictures.
Yeah.
I'm very excited about that.
And you can customize it.
I've got another one.
I mean we,
I mean this is just the beginning,
like,
yeah,
I'm gonna have a lot of fun with it.
I get,
I get this for you.
Want to do it.
Okay,
cool.
Enjoy.
Um,
so,
um,
let's,
let's venture forth bravely if,
if we may,
oh,
we're doing this still.
Yeah.
Okay.
This is why I brought you here.
You want to talk about your movie gone
clearly,
but the pizzas fucking good.
Like you could say,
oh,
wagner was a Nazi.
You could bog and it was a Nazi,
but like his music was pretty Dang.
Dang is the word.
I think he was hoping people would think
it was.
Dang.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
you know,
the chick filet thing,
it's like those sandwiches pretty good.
Pretty fucking.
Dang.
Well that's the conversation.
Can we separate the art from the pizza
mogul?
Can we separate the two?
The garlic sauce from the what looks
like water logged young vampire,
right?
Yeah.
That's a good description.
I like that.
Some stuff,
some rumor that the garlic sauce is the
secret of,
of of his loss of his long life.
Is that right?
Yeah,
it's like a slight more,
it's probably quite the opposite for
everyone else.
You think he's,
he doesn't drink that garlic sauce.
I drink it.
You do fucking,
I throw the pizza out.
I drink that shit.
No you don't.
They're in school.
I used to need in that in school we used
to,
um,
I get like fifth grade we would line up
shots of a Russian dressing,
like we do dress.
Did you like the dressing or was it
meant to be gross?
It was like at that age where it's like
there's no,
you're not doing drugs and stuff,
so you're like getting it to cassie.
Yeah.
Gimme like sweet or there was one friend
we used to pay to eat anything weird
like,
and he was up for anything that reminds
me of that.
Ethan.
Any fucking thing I'm telling you,
Bro?
Hair really dog shit.
Okay.
$1 way.
Anything wait,
he aided dollar or four.
$1.
Okay.
I'll give you a $1 eight a dollar.
I thought you were trying to get worse.
Come and do you need anything?
Hair.
Shit.
A dollar.
Well,
to be frank,
that may be the grossest one.
Yeah.
Who?
Dollar earners.
I had friends.
These do poo dollar.
Oh,
was that you put poo on a dollar and you
leave it outside like Oh yes.
And was like a dollar.
Yeah.
And then there's the shit on it,
but it's like,
it was a lot of jackass.
That was a big part of my childhood.
I met Cityville sweet guy.
Oh,
he was on here.
I was like,
he's really cool.
Okay.
Yeah.
They were important.
I agree.
Um,
as important as papa.
MMM,
thanks.
That was another one.
That was a different one.
It's so loud.
All these experts in culinary.
All right.
Don't act like you didn't pay everyone
to be here.
You fucking,
I'm very proud to be here in this
advertisement I paid for.
And the racism in Hind sight is pretty,
is there is a good old boy.
Yeah.
And all the ways that a good old boy as
a good way,
but also just like the mural.
I don't really,
the mural is killing me.
These giant onions.
Yeah.
The harvest.
The bouncy was sweet this year,
Papa.
And just like the sharp,
who do you think,
who do you think pick those.
Let me just put it that way.
On Papa's a plantation pass look at is
three Oh nine one 53 down.
Alright.
Bye.
Anyway,
this,
this isn't why we're here.
Are you?
I'm out of water and can I,
can I get a glass,
a little reader though?
Can we get a refill for Christ's sake?
Thank you.
So this is really the,
uh,
the Croup de Gras.
Is that how you sat?
Right?
Coupe de Gras.
Can this be a coup de Gras?
This video?
No,
I don't think so.
Me Tell.
It just looks confused.
I don't know if that is what does the
coup de Gras,
it's like the,
the final blow.
Yeah,
Yeah.
Thank you.
Yay.
Um,
I'm waiting for God.
He's the worst.
It's all good.
Hey,
good guys and the intern now he's the
worst.
You don't know him.
I don't say that.
You don't know him like you're just
being nice.
Don't do it.
Thanks you.
And you're the best.
Appreciate you.
And you've got the bottoms of that track
suit.
Yes.
Oh,
is that good or bad?
I don't know.
Some telling you,
but he's not wearing them.
You don't like the whole Adidas track
suit?
Look note on him.
I'm on board now,
Dude.
Fuck that guy.
Alright,
so this is in its entirety,
this beautiful,
wonderful advertisement that Papa John
made with his son as paper helper and
his best friend Beau,
to celebrate their Papa john.com.
Come in live 2010 and this is the title
they used.
This isn't someone else.
They put this here popping son.
First order on the new Papa john.com.
Okay?
Okay.
All right.
Okay,
welcome to [inaudible].
Now the first thing I already love about
this is like,
I'm so relatable and behind me is a
muzzle Liam.
Yeah.
It's like a fucking huge statue of an
eagle.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
I love it.
Also,
if he's gets a wedding ring is,
that'd be the thing is it's glyphic Oh,
a lot.
Yeah.
A lot of pizza's been sold to them by
that.
I'll say just cruising around in his
papa John.
Sure.
Like this is how I hang out at home.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
The low,
the untuck long sleeve.
The Long Sleeve Collard,
Papa John's shirt.
I love the idea of him just wearing that
every day at home.
It projects business yet casual rolled
up sleeves are worker.
Um,
you know,
I was just,
digging one of my maid's graves.
Oh,
hey there.
Yeah.
Oh,
you caught me.
I was just dedicated grave for one of my
fallen maids.
The secret ingredient.
That's a good one,
bro.
Did you really have to do this at your
fucking house?
Here's the steeple.
Open the doors.
No Jews.
That's Papa Johns.
Papa Johns.
What was that?
Was that one of the old school
playground thing?
Here's,
Oh,
of course you don't know this.
Here's the church.
Here's the steeple.
Open the doors.
Look at all the people.
No choose allows a twist.
No,
it's not a twist.
It's like,
oh,
they used to say that back in 2010
people say that about Jews to know that
he little.
No,
no Jews.
I feel like he should have done this
somewhere else as all like you have a
fucking dragon in your hall and like
made of gold in your hallway.
Like,
wait,
what is that?
Well,
it looks like a,
it's something.
Let's get it looks like a guera dose.
It's hard to tell man.
Is that a mythical creature?
No,
it's w what magic harp evolves into.
Oh yeah.
That's a mythical creature.
Don't say now.
Can you imagine he had a pokemon statue?
It's not a myth.
Pokemon sign methods only.
I wish so much that pokemon was real and
when I was a kid,
oh my God.
Dude was like snapping man.
It was where it was at.
I didn't play snap and that was the bast
y.
What was snapped?
The picture?
One rent.
Oh,
the one to take pictures.
I don't,
it was like perfect.
It was crazy.
For 64 I'm waiting for pokemon on the
switch,
man.
I can't fucking wait for three D
pokemon.
Ooh,
I'm not greedy.
Yeah,
well you know like,
oh yeah,
like a,
Ya know what?
I'm so talk,
talk to totally did.
I'm saying fucking hell.
So relatable,
man.
So glad you did it in your fucking
house.
Like why did you do this in your house?
Do it.
Had a pizza store.
He's almost like he's flexing on us.
Yeah,
it's a lot.
It is to grow up.
I have,
I feel both.
I feel for this kid.
He's like,
yeah,
well you can see the deadness in his
eyes.
I mean here.
Yeah,
port bow.
He still hasn't gotten over.
This blows the house.
Oh,
that's so sad.
Yeah,
no it is.
I,
oh,
his body to the,
the,
the baggy shirts.
Not High in the bow.
In the house.
Post the weakest hands in the air.
It's like the damn how old?
It's a weight.
That kids,
what I will say,
he's probably 12 or 13 so he's 20 now.
Yeah.
But if you're out there,
dude,
I love you.
We forgive you.
Your dad made bomb ass pizzas but you do
not have to be what he is.
I mean,
I hope you make pizzas.
I hope you carry on that family legacy
because that is a valuable,
I like the pizzas.
Yeah.
Maybe you should start bows pizza.
A boat shed himself of the hall.
You're going to have to change the
spelling though.
Cause people won't relate to that.
Yeah.
You don't have to live in the shadow of
your father.
You can do your own pizza thing.
Yeah.
Not Anything.
Yes you can do.
I was afraid you were going to say you
can do any,
no,
no.
You can do anything in the pizza
industry world.
The world's your gem.
This is like foxcatcher.
Have you seen foxcatcher [inaudible]
this is like what I wish foxcatcher
well,
I mean,
foster had one my favorite movies ever.
What is it?
But John Dupont who like,
uh,
this is crazy millionaire billionaire
who like had a bunch of raw like
wrestlers come,
uh,
wrestle on is like mansion property.
It's like a documentary at the movies
with Steve Corel and channing tatum and
Mark Rufallo.
It's incredible.
It's so weird and amazing,
but these are my,
that I miss that.
Um,
almost would like to watch a reality
show with these till.
Yeah,
almost.
We're fine often.
Jarbo I feel I love you maddie.
What's this whole
angle like?
It's like,
they're like,
we need a family angle on this.
I get to do with you.
You know,
after this camera goes off,
he's like,
fuck you dad.
Yeah,
of course.
I don't know.
You know what though?
I don't know if they love each other.
I mean,
I think bose genuine.
I think he's a real dude.
And really in this moment,
you think he's being real well here,
let me play it.
Cut Him.
I pizza.
He's got all the moves.
I'm just waiting for the thunder to
settle.
Okay.
I high tech low pizza.
I'm scared.
And wish you had a relationship with
mom's still.
Yeah.
I'm anxious all the time and uh,
I prefer a little caesars,
frankly.
Uh Huh.
Call Him Jalapenos.
To be frank with you.
I know it's Jalapeno and ever since was
a hell of what?
Yeah,
how a peanut,
that's what he said.
Right,
right.
I know.
Talapin Yo,
it's Jalapeno Jalapeno.
It's that all the yet I know that.
I know that.
I know what the double l means.
Can I say that?
Double l Jalapeno,
the double a mix.
A Y sound.
Are we confused?
Is there two l's and Jalapeno?
Oh my God.
I don't think there are.
Right.
Okay.
The point is let's,
let's go.
Let's,
let's rewind this.
It's not Michael Peanut Ania yet.
Hold on.
Let's rewind this anytime I sound like
an idiot.
I go,
I'm dyslexic,
but by the point I want it to be
successful with a learning disability.
I was looking,
I'm kidding.
You can have it.
You can be,
you can be successful with a learning
disability.
This jess ask Mozart Einstein.
Exactly.
He was asperger.
He,
he had asperger's.
He was an ass.
I thought that that's how it was.
Said No.
Um,
I know that it's Jalapeno.
Jalapeno Jalapeno.
Okay.
Jalapeno.
I know it was something like that.
Okay,
but once I watched the video,
you didn't Jalapeno.
Am I getting it?
Am I okay?
My passing the test.
A sea cow.
Wow.
I'm sorry.
I'll stop.
No,
please write that button to Valhalla.
Um,
but once I watched this,
I started saying how a Pena and I
couldn't stop.
Yes.
And it's actually a problem.
I call it a Jalapeno now it's all so
like who,
you know,
whatever.
Yeah,
we could,
we could end it there.
I'm saying we're mostly white and yeah,
silver Butrans,
you know what I mean?
We're doing croissant and we can have
our way,
whatever.
You don't have our way,
but like when it,
when,
when like when,
when the late lane white person like
overreaches too,
that's all we,
that's,
that's also like,
you know,
just normal.
It's like all good or well it's weird
when they go,
like when they go like a heat dad,
it's just like,
oh yeah,
what do you think you are?
You're my dad does that all the time.
Do when we go to Mexican restaurants?
Yeah.
He starts doing like jive with the,
with the Mexican waiters.
It's like speaking fucked up Spanish to
them.
Right.
I'm like,
Dude,
how do you even know they speak Spanish?
They're probably American,
but maybe it's respect cause I was just
thinking.
I don't know.
It can,
yeah,
you're saying it.
I'm saying I if like if I can find it
embarrassing.
I'm saying with some like Chinese guy
came over and was like,
hamburger.
I'd be like,
thanks.
I don't know.
So maybe it's cool.
Well thanks for being thoughtful.
Hey,
look at me like a hamburger.
That's a very funny thing is actually in
Sweden they did a show where they like
speaking in,
they're doing the equivalent of like for
Swedish,
we'd be like,
oh,
when we were like Walter Walter Walter
Boards or whatever,
and they do it for a English.
They don't,
they're not speaking English,
but what English is that correct to them
and it's a bunch of people going like a
hurt,
a corrupt [inaudible] subpar.
Ralph had read to total Achara.
Right.
I guess that's what it sounds like to
them.
It's all like our base shinder grade.
Yeah.
That's a good one to look up,
but also if you are a minority,
please hit them with those hard r's next
time you see me.
Yeah.
It'll be very respectful.
Well,
I can't,
Hi John.
Hit that harder.
Yeah,
he hit that are a little too hard.
Don't hit it that hard.
Don't ever hit that one.
Um,
but I can't,
I can't really tell if it's respectful
or embarrassing to like speak fucked up
Spanish to somebody.
You know,
I,
you know that maybe my dad.
Yeah,
that's probably low over your dad.
No,
because like,
I know people that are fluent,
they're like,
of course,
no,
but everything he does embarrass me,
you know?
And I'm,
I'm like a grown man and he's still is
capable of embarrassing me.
So brutally.
Did I hold my head in shame?
Yeah.
That's part of the power.
The Dad's wheeled.
It's beautiful though.
Yeah.
That's the job.
Okay.
Well regardless,
we are,
we,
we were flying through them.
We really got to push it like this.
Yeah.
You fucking idiot.
Why would you even admit that it's not
endearing?
He thought it was endearing.
You know,
I've never been on the Internet before.
Is that right?
Is that what laptops looked like eight
years ago?
Eight years like Dell that you'd like,
this is really a time capsule of like
eight years,
eight short years.
He was,
the chairs looked like back then rich.
Right.
People were living in castles back then.
Wow.
Things were much better.
Where are the bone chilling where all
those sounds that we know he makes,
I wish we had the hose on them.
I need those.
Damn,
we're going to have to sound bite those.
Okay.
It seemed to really have endured some
heat on that
couple of Saudi pups.
Oh,
we need to sound bites.
Saudi pops.
So I again,
I hurt.
I've watched this video and I can't stop
saying Saudi pops now.
Yeah.
Sodie pop story,
which is so good and it's cute.
So good.
It is cute.
It's sweet thing.
Oh,
there was a little full pod there.
There was a little mess up there and I
haven't noticed before.
Okay.
Yeah,
I thought it was someone off screen and
being like,
all right.
Okay,
so we're okay.
Great.
Oh wait,
you were actually,
I was like,
well,
I don't remember it being there.
Okay.
There's really not much to say at this
point.
I feel like,
uh,
just a couple of old good old boys
ordering it.
Bye.
Oh here.
This is great.
This is nailed.
That one.
I Love Matt.
Loved Matt while look at Matt.
You know what Matt is real mad is real.
Oh yeah.
No,
Matt didn't even know they were
shooting.
You really tell it like it is real.
That's why I love math so much.
And here's this point where Papa,
he needs to point out.
Here you can see,
gave you a tip.
Big 10.
Nice boat.
You'd get it dude.
I was like,
Dad,
I feel a kinship with this kid.
You liked the most dad,
the business.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
He's a,
he's got this sweet ass like you know,
sort of straight.
Yeah.
He's got this thing.
I feel good.
You are go.
All right,
so here,
I want to wrap it up with this beautiful
last moment here.
Matt,
you made history today.
God dammit.
Good Job Matt.
You're the greatest man
and as a prize you get to fuck my wife
in front of me.
You think he let Matt in?
He's got that vibe.
He's going to cook couple days.
Literally.
We can't even say cuckolding anymore
because now it's got political.
Oh,
that's true.
It's kind of lost all meaning.
Well that was it.
That's all I have
bro.
I a lot of fun.
Thanks for being here.
It was,
it was really an honor and a pleasure to
meet you and hang out with Dka and be
part of this.
I've been gone a long time.
Viewer first time B are here.
That's insane that you wash your stuff.
Thank you.
And I want it.
Well,
you're doing good work and I appreciate
it and like,
um,
thanks.
A lot of other people do.
And the girl in the movie is a huge fan
of yours.
So excited.
I loved her.
So,
so excited.
Can I do to like show her appreciation?
I don't know.
Just she,
she just hearing this.
She'll be,
she's amazing.
I love her Elsie Fisher.
She's great.
If you're in New York or La,
I see the movie and it will be other
places,
uh,
other,
other times,
99% on rotten tomatoes.
This movie is a heartwarming,
it's wholesome.
It's all fucking romp.
It's a beautiful,
a little slice of life.
It's,
it's going to,
you're going to love it and you're going
to leave thinking about it and the best
way possible.
Can I say that?
You just said it.
I said I didn't need permission.
Thank you,
Ethan.
Please go see eighth grade.
It's going to be out nationwide in two
weeks.
And thank you so much beau.
You can see it in New York and La,
but it's kind of hard.
Thank you for having me.
It,
it's kind of hard to catch.
It's in select select theaters.
Yeah.
You know,
catch it.
If you can,
it'll be like 10 more cities next
weekend and then everywhere that weekend
after everywhere.
Everywhere,
baby.
Right.
Thank you Beau.
Thank you guys for watching.
Uh,
we love you and appreciate you and we
will most definitely be seeing you next
week.
Thanks everybody.
Todd,
todd
[inaudible].